ओके
सो आई थिंक आईम लाइव नाउ लेट्स
वेट चलिए
तो लाइव आ चुके
हैं लेट मी चेक गाइस लेट मी वेरीफाई वनस
प्लीज जस्ट वेट एंड आप लोग मुझे बता दीजिए
लाइव आर व लाइव नाउ
गाइस ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही है प्लीज कंफर्म
गाइस प्लीज कंफर्म कर दीजिए सभी
लोग इज द ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग
इज
गुड चलिए
तो
ओके
ग्रेट काफी लोग आ चुके हैं यहां पर हमारे
साथ जुड़ चुके हैं काफी
लोग
लेट मी सी कितने लोग हैं यहां पर ओके
शैलेश पंकज आरसी टेक शैलेश हो गए टेक्निकल
स्वरूप शांके
राहुल टेक जीनियस
नचिकेत ओके स्ट्रेंज
लीडर आदर्श ठाकुर वाइट हैकर ओके वेलकम
एवरी बडी वेलकम टू द सेशन एंड
टुडेज टॉपिक इज वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग बहुत
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक होने वाला है
काफी कुछ हम एकदम प्रैक्टिकल देखने वाले
हैं करने वाले हैं मिस करोगे लाइव तो बहुत
कुछ मिस करोगे मतलब रिकॉर्डिंग में वो मजा
नहीं आने वाला है आज के सेशन में जो लाइव
में आने वाला है तो आज का सेशन है 12थ एंड
वेलकम
एवरीबॉडी कोर्स एंड आज के इस क्लास में हम
जावास्क्रिप्ट हंटिंग करने वाले हैं एंड
देखेंगे कैसे एज एन एथिकल हैकर एज अ बग
बाउंट हंटर आप जावास्क्रिप्ट्स फाइल्स जो
होती हैं कोई आपके टारगेट जो होते हैं जो
भी जिससे कि आपकी परमिशन होती है जिस हंट
करने की आप वहां से कैसे उससे सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल पाते हैं तो वी आर गोइंग
टू सी अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स लॉट ऑफ स्टफ टुडे
तो प्लीज डोंट मिस द लाइव सेशन बिकॉज लाइव
में आज जो मजा है ना वो फिर वैसे नहीं आने
वाला है रिकॉर्डेड में ठीक
है
ओके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग एवरी बडी गुड
इवनिंग सर आई हैव फाउंड सब डोमेन व्हिच
हैज सी नेम ऑफ एडब्ल्यू बट आई डोंट हैव
एनी अकाउंट कैन आई रिपोर्ट दिस अ आपके पास
अगर एडब्ल्यू पे पॉइंट कर रहा है पहले आप
देखिए एडब्ल्यू पे कौन सी सर्विस पे पॉइंट
कर रहा है क्लाउड फ्रंट पे अगर कर रहा है
तो क्लाउड फ्रंट इज नॉट वल्नरेबल एनी मोर
ठीक है तो उसमें आप नहीं कर सकते कुछ भी
सबको नमस्ते सबको सबको सबको गुड इवनिंग
सबको गुड इवनिंग सबको हेलो ठीक है चलिए तो
स्टार्ट करते हैं ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे हम आज से बहुत ज्यादा टाइम नहीं
लेने वाले हैं एंड आई होप कि जो मैंने
आपको बताया हुआ है जो मैंने आपको टास्क
दिया है आप सब वो टास्क कर रहे हैं
तो आज का सेशन आज के सेशन में देखो मैंने
आपको पहले ही बताया हुआ है गाइस कल मैं
सेशन नहीं ले पाया ड्यू टू सम अ हेल्थ
इश्यूज ज्यादा कुछ अच्छा फील कर नहीं रहा
था तो मैं सेशन नहीं ले पाया इसलिए आज का
सेशन बहुत धमाकेदार होने वाला है एंड आज
के सेशन में हम देखेंगे रेकन की पावर को
रेकन मैंने आपको पहले ही बताया ना कि रेकन
पे लंबी सेशन चलेगी एंड रेकन इतनी बड़ी है
इतनी
कॉम्प्लेक्शन करते करते थक जाओगे बट रेकन
का प्रोसेस खत्म नहीं होने वाला है रेकन
के थ्रू आप इतनी चीजें फाइंड फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो जिसका आपको आईडिया तक नहीं होगा
वो सारी चीजें फाइंड आउट आप कर सकते हो
ठीक है तो चलिए सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं
स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको सिंपल
सा यहां पे आपको बता देता हूं यह मेरा
[संगीत]
नेक्स्ट अगर आप क्लाउड में बग बाउंट
हंटिंग करना चाहते हैं क्लाउड में मशीन
सेटअप करना चाहते हैं तो डिजिटल ओन मैं
यूज़ कर रहा हूं कुछ टाइम से एडब्ल्यू को
डिच कर दिया मैंने एंड डिजल ओसन के आप
यूज़ कर सकते हैं इसी वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक है आप उस पे जाएं
और वहां से अगर आप साइन अप करते हैं तो
आपको $200 का क्रेडिट मिलता है फ्री
ट्रायल मिलता है दो महीनों के लिए जैसे
मुझे यहां पे मिला हुआ है एंड आप उसको
यूज़ कर सकते हैं कोई भी मशीन यूज़ कर
सकते हैं फिलहाल मेरा जो मशीन है उसमें
4gb की मेमोरी है 80gb की हार्ड डिस्क लगी
हुई है एंड 4 टेराबाइट की बैंडविथ मिल रही
है तो चलिए मशीन को हम अपने स्टार्ट कर
लेते हैं यहां पे मुझे आईपी मिल चुकी है
नाउ आई विल सिंपली कॉपी दिस आईपी आईपी को
कॉपी करके आप किसी भी अपने टर्मिनल में आप
इसको एसएसए कर सकते हैं आपने मशीन को जैसे
स्टार्ट कर लिया है आपके डिजिटल
अ लाइक डिजिटल ओसियन की इसकी वीडियो पहले
वाली लाइव सेशन में ऑलरेडी आपको बता दी गई
है स्पेसिफिक वीडियो कैसे इस पे मशीन
सेटअप करना है आप देख सकते हो उसको तो हम
यहां पे क्या करते हैं हम यहां पे पावर
शेल का यूज कर सकते हैं तो विज पावर शेल
का यूज कर लेते हैं इस बार हम यहां पे मैं
इसको ज़ूम आउट जूम इन कर देता हूं यहां पे
थोड़ा सा अ लेट्स जूम इन ठीक है अब यहां
पे हम एसएसए करेंगे एंड रूट हमारा यूजर
नेम होने वाला है एंड ये हमारी आईपी होने
वाली है सिंपली हम यहां पे पासवर्ड
डालेंगे जो भी आपने पासवर्ड क्रिएट किया
रहेगा वो पासवर्ड डाल दीजिएगा एंड उसके
बाद आप लॉग इन कर सकते हैं यहां परमिशन
डिनाइड आ रहा है पासवर्ड में कुछ गड़बड़ी
हो गई होगी लेट्स फिक्स इट एंड इट्स अ
करेक्ट इट शुड बी करेक्ट नाउ अभी भी ओके
कैप्स लॉक ऑन हो गया था वापस से हम ट्राई
कर लेते हैं एंड अब जो है लॉग इन हो जाना
चाहिए हमारा मशीन लॉगइन हो चुका है अगर आप
देखेंगे कैट
ईटीसी देन ओस एंड देन रिलीज तो आपको पता
चलेगा यह यन टू की मशीन है तो जी हां मैं
यहां पे यट की मशीन यूज कर रहा हूं एंड
यहां साइड में मैंने एक मोबाइल फोन मेरा
यूज कर रहा हूं आपके चैट्स को देखने के
लिए तो अगर आपकी कोई चैट हो है जो भी है
मैसेज आप वहां डाल सकते हैं एंड आई विल बी
सीइंग बीच-बीच में ठीक
है प्री सिक्योरिटी 80 पर डन है बढ़िया जब
आप ट्राई हैमी के लैब्स को कर लेते हैं
कंप्लीट तो आप
कीजिए एंड हमारी कंपनी मुझे टैग कर सकते
हैं ताकि मुझे पता चल जाए कि व्हाट वी आर
डूइंग एंड इसका बेनिफिट हमें मिल रहा है
तो हम यहां पे आ चुके हैं अ हमारे मशीन के
ऊपर में यहां एलएस मैं करता हूं अपनी
फाइल्स यहां दिखा देता हूं कुछ भी नहीं है
यहां पे बेसिकली सिंपल खाली सी चीज है
दैट्ची क्योंकि जब समझेंगे तो आपको करने
में मजा भी आएगा ठीक है चलिए सिंपल मैं
यहां पे नोट पैड ओपन कर लेता हूं एक नया अ
यहां पे अ टैब ओपन कर लेता हूं आज हम करने
वाले हैं जावा
स्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स
एनालिसिस एनालिसिस फॉर फॉर सीक्रेट
इंफॉर्मेशन
इंफॉर्मेशन इंफॉर्मेशन
या लीकेज अब यह कैसा इंफॉर्मेशन हो सकता
है जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स में क्या एनालाइज
करेंगे कैसी होती है यह सारी चीजें
देखेंगे देखो मैं आपको एक सिंपल सा एक
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल का एक ओवरव्यू दे देता
हूं पहले ताकि आपको अच्छे से समझ आ जाए तो
मैं यहां पे एक ब्राउजर ओपन करता हूं एंड
यहां पे मैं
google.com ठीक है मैंने ffr.in
बहुत तरह की चीजें यहां पे एचटीएमएल
सीएसएस जावास्क्रिप्ट के यहां पे आपको
कोड्स दिखने को मिल जाएंगे क्लाइंट साइड
कोड्स जिसको आप बोलते हैं मैं यहां पे
कंट्रोल एफ करूंगा एंड मैं यहां पे क्या
करूंगा डॉट जेएस कर दूंगा डॉट जेएस आपको
यहां पे दिख रहा होगा 40 मैचेस यहां पे
दिख रहे हैं चलिए 40 मैचेस में देखते हैं
यहां पे क्या करते हैं एक बार नेक्स्ट
करते हैं यहां पे आप देखिए यहां पे ये रहा
एक मैच लेट्स फाइंड
आउट ये
देखिए यहां पे एक
एक जेएस वाली यहां पे लिंक हमें मिली है
क्या लिंक मिली है यह वाली लिंक मिली है
मुझे डॉट जेएस वाली चलिए इस लिंक को मैं
कॉपी करता हूं एक नए टैब में ओपन करता हूं
जब मैं ओपन करूंगा तो यहां पे आपको बहुत
सारी खिच पिच खिच पिच इंफॉर्मेशन मिल रही
है ठीक है अब ये इंफॉर्मेशन ना एक पिटारा
है किसका एक पिटारा कुछ सेंसिटिव सीक्रेट
इंफॉर्मेशन या लीकेज का यानी कि आप इन
जेएस लिंक्स पे कुछ ऐसे कीवर्ड्स डाल के
आपको व चीजें फाइंड करनी है जो सेंसिटिव
हो सकती है जो बहुत ही ज्यादा सेंसिटिव हो
सकती है एंड आप जब उनको फाइंड करके जब
रिपोर्ट करोगे बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म पे
किसी भी प्लेटफॉर्म पे किसी भी प्रोग्राम
को लेके वो p1 प2 कैटेगरी में आ सकती है
p3 कैटेगरी में आ सकती है मतलब p1 टू पी3
में मेनली देखे जाते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोजर के अंदर यह वनबिल आप रिपोर्ट
कर सकते हो एंड दिस इज क्वाइट अ हैंडफुल
ऑफ फाइंडिंग वेरी वेरी जूसी इंफॉर्मेशन
फ्रॉम
जावास्क्रिप्ट लिंक्स
अब अब यहां हमारा मोटिव क्या होना चाहिए
मतलब हमारा टारगेट क्या होना चाहिए मैं
आपको बता देता हूं हमारा टारगेट होना
चाहिए सबसे पहले स्टेप वाइज हम जाएंगे
फाइंड अ टारगेट एक अच्छा टारगेट लेंगे
टारगेट का मतलब यहां पर डोमेन फाइंड
करेंगे ठीक है सबसे पहले तो हम ये डोमेन
फाइंड करेंगे दूसरा हमारा मोटिव क्या होना
चाहिए
फाइंड फाइंड ऑल द
पॉसिबल ऑल द पॉसिबल सब डोमस और और लिंक्स
फ्रॉम द टारगेट सब डोमस और लिंक्स का मतलब
और लिंक्स फ्रॉम द टारगेट एज वेल इट्स सब
डोमेन इसका मतलब क्या है कि इस पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट का मान लो मेरा टारगेट डेनिक्स है
मान लो अभी के लिए de.com है अब fix.com
वेबसाइट पे जितने भी लिंक्स है सब लिंक्स
को कलेक्ट कर लीजिए जितने भी लिंक्स आते
हैं यह तो सिर्फ जावास्क्रिप्ट के लिंक है
मैं बोल रहा हूं जितने भी लिंक्स आते हैं
सबको कलेक्ट कर लीजिए उन लिंक्स में से जो
जावास्क्रिप्ट वाले जो अंदर यूआरएल आपको
मिलेंगे उनको निकाल लेंगे और उन
जावास्क्रिप्ट यूआरएल के अंदर हम
सीक्रेट्स फाइंड करेंगे हम सीक्रेट्स
फाइंड करेंगे क्या हो सकते हैं वो
सीक्रेट्स क्याक सीक्रेट्स हो सकते हैं
चलिए मैं आपको थोड़ा सीक्रेट का भी
एग्जांपल दिखाई देता हूं तो मैं एक
रिपोजिटरी ओपन कर रहा हूं
अ अभी आप लोग इस पर ज्यादा ध्यान मत दीजिए
इस परे भी हम आ जाएंगे जल्दी ही आ
जाएंगे लेट्स
वेट कितने लोग हैं 59 ओनली 59 है बट ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं ओनली 59 आप लोग है अच्छा
तो नहीं लग रहा है आई थिंक 100 प्लस होने
चाहिए क्योंकि मतलब क्या बोलू मैं चलिए ये
एक न्यूक्लि टेंप्लेट का ठीक है यह
रिपोजिटरी है लेकिन मैं आपको दूसरा दिखाता
[संगीत]
हूं यहां पे रिमाइंड मी टुमारो एक मैं गट
रे री पे चल रहा हूं यहां पे एंड यहां पे
आप आएंगे गिट रिपोजिटरी पे ये न्यूक्लियर
टेंपलेट्स है इनके पास एक मैं फाइल में
चलता हूं यहां पे वेब जेएस को एक्सपेंड कर
देता हूं एंड j एलाइज एक्स
ml5 डब्ल्यू डी पास पीडब्ल्यूडी प्राइवेट
क्रेडेंशियल ऑथ क्रेड क्रेड सी ट एक्सेस
टोकेंस यह सारी चीजें आपको फाइंड करनी है
इसके अलावा मैं और भी दिखाता हूं यहां पे
यह देखिए पास ड्डी रोक स्लैक फ बेस स्गर
एडब्ल्यू सीक्रेट की एडब्ल्यू की पासवर्ड
एफटीपी पासवर्ड जेबीडी जेडीबीसी डीबी एएल
सीक्रेट जट कॉन्ग एडमिन पीडब्ल्यूडी जसन
जीसीप ए एकस एवी एसएसए कीड गट एक्सेस की
सीक्रेट टोकन ऑथ ये सारे जो आपके कीवर्ड्स
हैं ये ऐसे कीवर्ड्स हैं अगर यह कीवर्ड्स
आपको किसी पर्टिकुलर जावास्क्रिप्ट लिंक प
मिलते हैं तो ये सेंसिटिव कीवर्ड्स है अब
यहां पे मान लो आपको एडब्ल्यूएल जाती है
आपको रोक की कोई की मिल जाती है तो आप उस
की का यूज करके बेसिकली उस पर्टिकुलर
अकाउंट के लिए जो भी उस की की जो भी
प्रिविलेज होंगे उस लेवल तक के कंट्रोल कर
सकते हैं उस लेवल तक का एक्सेस आप कर सकते
हैं एंड ये एक p1 प2 कैटेगरी की वनबिल
कहलाती है यानी कि आप सिंपली एक्सेस टू द
अकाउंट या अकाउंट एक्सेस की बात कर रहे
हैं यहां पे अकाउंट कंप्रोमाइज की बात कर
रहे हैं यहां पे यानी कि यह जो है आप जब
रिपोर्ट करेंगे तो आपको अच्छी खासी बाउंट
मिलेगी अगर आपको इस तरह का कोई सेंसिटिव
कीवर्ड मिल जाता है जावास्क्रिप्ट के
लिंक्स के अंदर या जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स
के अंदर ठीक है यानी कि कुछ इस तरह की
जावास्क्रिप्ट की आपकी फाइल्स होंगी जैसे
यहां पे हमारी वेबसाइट क्या आई है अब
इसमें एक ही जावास्क्रिप्ट थोड़ी ना यार
ये तो एक मैंने देखा चलो नीचे आते हैं ये
देखो एक ये भी लिंक है इस पे क्लिक करो
इसमें भी कुछ है देखा फिर नीचे आ जाओ और
भी बहुत सारे मिलेंगे यह वाली लिंक है
जावास्क्रिप्ट इस पर क्लिक करो इस पर भी
तुम्हें बहुत सारे मिल जाएंगे फिर वैसे ही
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट करते जाओ
ऐसे बहुत सारे लिंक्स अब मैनुअली इतना
लिंक कौन निकालेगा यार कहां से इतना
मैनुअली पॉसिबल है कि इतने लिंक्स प जा जा
ऐसे करें मैनुअल हंटिंग भी बहुत अच्छा
होता है वैसे जावास्क्रिप्ट की आप मैनुअल
हंटिंग करोगे ज्यादा बेटर होता है ज्यादा
अच्छे से आपको चीजें मिलने के चांसेस होते
हैं बट थोड़ा ऑटोमेशन भी कर लेंगे भाई
क्या जाता है हमारा क्या दिक्कत आ रही है
ऑटोमेशन करने में कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है
ओके ओके ठीक है
चलिए ओके चलिए तो कुछ खास यहां पे नहीं है
हमारे पास मैसेज कुछ मैसेजेस हैं जो यहां
पे आउट ऑफ यहां पे अभी कवरेज है तो उनको
मैं अभी नहीं ले रहा अ ठीक है अभी हम उनको
कंसीडर नहीं कर रहे हैं अभी सिर्फ और
सिर्फ जावास्क्रिप्ट एंड इस पे एनालिसिस
के ऊपर है ठीक है चलिए मैं उसमें भी दूंगा
रिपोजिटरी भी दे दूंगा टेंशन आपको नहीं
लेनी है ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लीजिए चलिए अब
स्टार्ट करते हैं इसकी एक्चुअल हंटिंग के
ऊपर किस तरीके से हमको हंट करना है इसको
किस तरीके से आगे हम इसको लेके जा सकते
हैं अब सबसे पहले यहां पे तो मेरा मशीन
क्लोज हो गया होगा मेरे ख्याल से यस क्लोज
हो चुका है आई न्यू दैट थोड़ी देर तक अ आप
कुछ नहीं करेंगे कनेक्ट हो जाते हैं
डिजिटल ओसियन के मशीन से तो रिसेट कनेक्शन
मतलब रिफ्यूज करके वो क्लोज हो जाता है
सिक्योरिटी पर्पस से ठीक है अब यहां पे
हमारा सबसे पहला मोटिव क्या होना चाहिए
मोटिव होना चाहिए हमारा मुझे बताइए आप
मुझे चैट में सभी लोग बताइए
सबसे पहला मोटिव क्या होना चाहिए फिर से
तो मैं नहीं बता सकता रिकॉर्डिंग देखना
पड़ेगा आपको क्योंकि आप लोग लेट अगर जवाइन
करते हैं तो मैं रिपीट नहीं कर सकता सॉरी
आप लोग टाइम पे आया कीजिए ज्यादा बेटर
होगा आपके लिए भी ठीक
है टेंशन मत लो आप लोग देखते जाओ अभी सब
सब कुछ होगा यहां पे सबसे पहले हमें क्या
करना है सबसे पहले हमें
जावास्क्रिप्ट के लिंक्स फाइंड करने हैं
क्या करने हैं जावास्क्रिप्ट के लिंक्स
फाइंड करने हैं कैसे फाइंड करने हैं भैया
हम पहले वो देखते हैं देखो इसके के लिए हम
दो बहुत ही पॉपुलर टूल का यूज करने वाले
हैं एक जो टूल है जिसका यूज करने वाले हैं
वो है कटाना दूसरा जो है यूज करने वाले
वोह है सब
जेएस कटाना एंड सब जेएस हम इनको यूज करने
वाले हैं दिस आर द टूल्स चलिए अब कैसे
इंस्टॉल करना है कैसे कन्फर करना है पहले
हम वो देख लेते हैं ठीक है सबसे पहले तो
हम अपने मशीन से ही कनेक्ट हो जाते हैं
क्योंकि मशीन से हमारा कनेक्शन लॉस्ट हो
चुका है ड्यू टू इन
एक्टिविटी
सबसे पहले सबसे पहले तो टारगेट चूज करना
पड़ेगा हमें तो चलिए हम टारगेट चूज कर
लेते हैं यहां पर बग क्राउड पर चलते बक
राउड प ही टारगेट चूज करेंगे कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है बकड पर चलते
हैं
ओके प्रोग्राम्स पर चलते
हैं ठीक है प्रोग्राम्स प आ गए कोई सा भी
एक प्रोग्राम चूज करते हैं कोई देख लेते
हैं हम यहां पर यह रिसेंट प्रोग्राम है
मनी के के
रैपिड
ओके यह भी एक रिसेंट प्रोग्राम है रैपिड
चलिए रैपिड को देख लेते हैं इसमें कितने
रिसर्चस है 537 है हल फेम 94 ठीक है 6 डेज
का वैलिडेशन ठीक है ओके एंड इनकी स्कोप
क्या है देख लेते हैं लेट्स सी द स्कोप
गाइस एपीआई डॉट ठीक है टारगेट वन में टियर
थ टियर टू के स्कोप्स
चेक आउट डॉट रप ठीक है एंड टियर वन के ओके
तोन स्कोप में इनकी वेबसाइट्स हैं और बहुत
सारी एक नहीं है बहुत सारी वेबसाइट्स हैं
rapid.com आर प्रेजेंट इन द
लाइक स्कोप
[संगीत]
दैट्ची नेट इसी को हम ले लेते हैं एंड इसी
के साथ हम आगे बढ़ते हैं बक राउड का ये
टारगेट है राइट चलिए नाउ यहां पे हम लॉगिन
तो हो चुके हैं सबसे पहले हम यूज करने
वाले हैं सब जेएस को एंड फॉर दैट वी नीड
टू गो टू सब जेएस गिट हब रिपोजिटरी बाकी
सारी चीजें मैं यहां पे क्लोज कर देता हूं
ताकि कोई प्रॉब्लम ना हो जस्ट क्लोज इट
एंड लेट्स टेक रैपिड एंड लेट्स गो टू द सब
जेएस गिट हब पेज सब जेएस को हम कं फिगर
करेंगे लेट्स गो टू सब जस ये टूल आपको
थोड़ा सा पुराना है बट
दैट्ची टूल है आप इसको यूज कर सकते हैं
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है चलिए तो इंस्टॉलेशन कैसे करना है आप
देख सकते हैं इंस्टॉलेशन के लिए सिंपली
यहां पे सोर्स से आप इस तरीके से कर सकते
हैं एंड सोर्स से मतलब इस तरीके से एंड
बाइनरी से आप इस तरीके से कर सकते हैं कोई
सा भी ऑप्शन आप यूज कर सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है एंड इसको आप पास कर सकते
हैं एक यूआरएल की डायरेक्टरी से अगर आपके
पास पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल है तो तो आप उसके
थ्रू पास कर सकते हैं अब सबसे पहली बात
यूआरएल अब वो यूआरएल तो चाहिए ना भैया तो
वो यूआरएल आपको मतलब यूआरएल का मतलब क्या
है यह देखिए यहां
पे मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं यहां
पे ये देखिए सब जेएस फेचेज जावास्क्रिप्ट
फाइल्स फ्रॉम ए लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल और सब
डोमस यानी कि अगर यूआरएल है कोई सब डोमेन
है तो उसे जावास्क्रिप्ट अ फाइल्स को ये
फेच करता है बस ये चीज है ठीक है अब यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं . txt.gz तो आपका काम
हो जाएगा एंड आपका जो भी जावास्क्रिप्ट
फाइल्स है वो आपके पास आ जाएगी ठीक है तो
यहां पे आपको हान आ देना है एंड इनपुट
करना है एंड
दैट्ची इसका काम क्या है आप इसको समझिए
कटाना को
देखिए फास्ट एंड फुली कॉन्फ़िगरेशन वेब
क्रॉल स्टैंडर्ड एंड हैडलेस मोड सपोर्ट
ठीक है जावास्क्रिप्ट पासिंग क्रॉ ंग करता
है ये कस्टमाइजेबल ऑटोमेटिक फॉर्म फीलिंग
ठीक है बहुत सारी चीजें ये करता है ठीक है
स्टडी इन आउटपुट वगैरह ये सब प्रोवाइड
करता है चलिए अब यहां पे आप आएंगे तो इसकी
ये हेल्प फाइल है अब इसको कंफिल कैसे करना
है तो हम दोनों को पहले यूज़ करते हैं हम
दोनों को ही ट्राई करेंगे एंड दोनों से ही
हम अ जो है फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेंगे स
सबसे पहले तो हमें चाहिए क्या हमें चाहिए
सब डोमेन क्या चाहिए भैया हमें सब डोमेन
अब ये सब डोमेन कहां से मिलेगा चलो
एलस करते हैं वेर इज द सब फाइंडर आर वी
हैव डू वी हैव सब फाइंडर एलस साइफन ए देख
लेते हैं सब फाइंडर है कि नहीं हमारे पास
अ सब फाइंडर ओके सब फाइंडर है हमारे पास
तो यहां पे सब फाइंडर मेरे पास है गाइस
चलिए बहुत बढ़िया नाउ आई एम गोइंग टू रन
सब फाइंडर टू कलेक्ट क्या कलेक्ट क्या सब
डोमेंस एंड उस सब डोमेन के हम जावा
स्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स को निकाल सकते हैं तो
चलिए हम पहले सब डोमस फाइंड करने की कोशिश
करते हैं किससे सब फाइंडर से से सबसे पहला
हमारा स्टेप तो लेट्स फाइंड द सब फाइंडर
डोमस सबसे पहले सब सब फाइंडर यूज़ करते
हैं तो सब फाइंडर हम यूज़ करते हैं हान डी
यूज़ कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे हम अपना
हमारा जो टारगेट है
[संगीत]
फाइल अ रड अ
सब फाइंडर कन्फ नहीं हो रही है तो कन्फी
कर लीजिए क्या बात है 80 लोग आ चुके हैं
ग्रेट यही तो सपोर्ट चाहिए भाई यही तो
चाहिए ये ऐसे रखोगे तो यार कंटेंट में ऐसी
धमाकेदार कंटेंट मिलेगी समझ नहीं पाओगे
तुम या ग जीयू इज आल्सो अ ग्रेट टूल यू
कैन यूज
दैट
लेट्स लेट इट फिनिश
गाइस बढ़िया बढ़िया हो गया बढ़िया है आपका
देखिए आप लोगों का सब फाइंडर अगर बहुत
जल्दी हो चुका है क्योंकि आपने एपीआई कीज
बहुत सारे नहीं कन्फर किए हैं यहां पर
मैंने एपीआई कीज कन्फर करे हैं बहुत सारे
बहुत सारे एपीआई कीज कन्फर कर दिए इसलिए
यह थोड़ा टाइम लगा रहा है सारे सर्विसेस
जो एपीआई कीज कन्फर हो चुकी है सबको यूज
करके ये सब डोमस फाइंड कर रहा है ठीक है
इसलिए यहां पर टाइम लग रहा है अदर वाइज
बहुत जल्दी हो जाता यह बात तो है राइट सो
लेट्स वेट एंड लेट्स लेट इट
कंप्लीट भाई जो पहले चल रहा है उसको तो
देख लो है
ना
चलिए देखा यह रिपोजिट बेसिकली जब आप एपीआई
कंफिल कर देते हो तो आपको काफी सारी जो है
ना वो सब डोमेंस मिल जाती है यहां पे बहुत
ज्यादा मिल जाती है तो देखिए अब देखते
जाइए
ओके लेट इट
कंप्लीट आपको मैं दिखा दूंगा बहुत सारे
एपीआई कन्फर किए हैं इसलिए दिस इ टेकिंग
टाइम एंड वी हैव टू वेट फॉर इट टू फिनिश
जितने भी सब डोमस है उनको फिनिश होने देते
हैं वेट करते हैं ठीक
है अरे भैया बैस स्क्रिप्टिंग का वीडियो
चाहिए जाइए डिफर अकेडमी
इसको चलने देंगे जब तक कंप्लीट नहीं होगा
बहुत सारी सब डोम हम फाइंड कर
लेंगे रप वाले भैया आरसी
टेक धन्यवाद आपको भी चलिए बहुत सार सबड
फाइंड कर लिए यार यह देख रहे हो यह नई नई
प्रोग्राम है रापिड नेट देखो कितनी सारी
सबड फाइंड की इसके ग्रेट र अभी तो बहुत
सारे फिल्टर हो जाएंगे बट स्टिल देरर लट
ऑफ सबमें र
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग सब डोमस भी एय r.net दिस
इंटरेस्टिंग दिस इ इंटरेस्टिंग एपीआई वाली
यह सैंड बॉक्स चेक आउट टिक ठीक है बढ़िया
है यह डेव डैशबोर्ड यह काफी अच्छा सब
डोमेन है डब रनेट डेव एपीआई दिस इ वेरी
गुड सब डोमेन कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग है यहां
पर ओके आइकॉन स्लिप सीएमएस ओके ओके ओ भाई
कितने निकालो ग सब डोमेन चलो फाइंड कर
लिया यहां सब डोमेन भाई ने 414 सब डोमेंस
निकाले हैं 414 सब डोमेंस ठीक है चलिए
यहां पे मैं क्लियर कर देता हूं एलएस करता
हूं यहां पे आपको ि t एकटी दिख रहा होगा
rapid.com है डब्लू सफन l 414 अब 414 सब
डोमेंस पे एसटीटीपी एक चला देना है ये तो
आपको पता ही होगा प्रूव कर लेते हैं एडीपी
एक पे क्या जाता है कितने इसमें से निकलते
हैं बढ़िया वाले तो चलिए यहां पे कै
एंड यहां निकालते हैं कैट के बाद क्या
करेंगे भाई
रैपिड एचटीटीपी एक्स ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है
आप इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा एटीपी एक को
इंस्टॉल कर लिया होगा एटीपी एक कर दिया अब
यहां पर सिंपली जो भी हमारे पास आउटपुट
आएगा उसको एक फाइल में डाल देते हैं
रैपिड
प्रोब्ड रैपिड ऐसे कर देते हैं फाइनल ड
एक्स चलिए ठीक है तो एटीटीपी एक ने अपना
काम करना शुरू कर दिया है
रैपिड
फाइनल ड एक्सटी एंड यहां पर कितने सब
डोमेन हमारे पास आ गए फाइनली 168 414 में
से 168 डोमेन जो है हमारे पास आ चुके हैं
बहुत बढ़िया अब इस डोमेन पे हम यहां प
पहले एलस करते और इस वाली फाइल को हटा
देते हैं आर एम रैपिड डटी एक्सटी जो है ना
इसको हम हटा देते हैं बिल्कुल रैपिड फाइनल
ओनली रहने देते हैं ट्स इट अब यहां आ गया
अब हम यहां पर क्या करने वाले हैं अब हम
यहां पर सबसे पहले सब जस चलाएंगे किस लिए
चलाएंगे फेच जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स फ्रॉम अ
लिस्ट ऑफ यूआरएल और सब डोमस जावास्क्रिप्ट
फाइल्स को फेच करने के लिए सबसे पहले हम
ये चलाएंगे उसके बाद वी कैन गो फॉर द
कटाना टूल आल्सो तो चलिए पहले हम सब जेएस
को कॉन्फ़िगर करते हैं इसके अ बाइनरी से
ही कर लेते हैं बहुत बढ़िया है यहां पे
क्या करना है सिंपल अ देख लेते हैं यहां
पे ओके रिलीज़ पेज पे चलना है
आपको रिलीज पेज पे चलना है एंड यह वाला है
आपका
यह वाली हमें चाहिए तो राइट क्लिक करते
हैं कॉपी लिंक कर लेते हैं कॉपी लिंक कहां
गया कॉपी लिंक लिंक कॉपी कर ली
एंड ओके ट्स इट लिंक कॉपी कर
ली डब्लू गेट कमांड से यहां पे पेस्ट कर
देते हैं एंड इसको हम डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
ठीक है जस्ट वेट ओके आई होप डाउनलोड हो
चुका होगा एलएस करते हैं या डाउनलोड हो
गया है इसको हम अनजिप मतलब अन टार कर लेते
हैं तो टार एक्स एक्ससवी एफ एंड देन सब जस
ठीक है तो इसको हम अन कर लेते हैं तो ये
एंटर हो चुका है अब यहां पे सॉरी अब यहां
पे एलएस करते हैं एक एक हमारे पास क्या आ
गया सब जेएस का एक बाइनरी आ गया ये बाइनरी
है आपको अब इसको एग्जीक्यूटेबल बनाना है
आपको सिस्टम वाइड तो आपको इसको किसी भी
पाथ पे मूव कर दीजिए सिंपल हो जाएगा पाथ
कैसे पता चलेगा इको एंड देन आप पाथ यहां
पे टाइप कीजिए आपको सारे पाथ जो हैं वो
पता चल जाएंगे जो भी पाथ अभी सेट है जो भी
पाथ में बने हुए हैं तो यहां पे आप यूएसआर
बिन यूएसआर एस बिन यूएसआर बिन में डाल
देते हैं यहां पे जिनो जो जो यहां पे बोला
गया होगा उसी में डाल देते हैं चलो
इन्होंने कहां बोला है डालने के लिए अ
यूजर बिन में ही डाला बोला हुआ है डालने
के लिए तो यूजर बिन में हम डाल देते हैं
तो एमवी कर देते हैं यहां से एंड सब जेएस
को मूव कर देते हैं स्ल एसआर स् बिन के
अंदर में ठीक है हमने उसको मूव कर दिया सब
जेएस को अब हम सब जीएस को डायरेक्टली यहां
से एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं हान ए करके
एंटर करते हैं एंड इट शुड बी
एग्जीक्यूटिंग एंड ये एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा
है सब जस की हेल्प फाइल आ चुकी है आपके
पास कैसे यूज करना है आप सबको बहुत अच्छे
से पता है चलिए पहले हम सिंपल सा देख लेते
हैं कैट कट
rapid.com सब डोमस हैं आपके अ उस डोमस के
अंदर में उसमें से ये जावास्क्रिप्ट के
फाइल्स निकाल रहा है यू कैन सी वी आर
गेटिंग जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स समझ रहा समझ
में आ रहा है सबको इतना समझ में आ रहा है
जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी बता दीजिए जल्दी
मैं देख रहा हूं मैं देख रहा हूं मैं देख
रहा हूं जल्दी बताइए जल्दी बताइए जल्दी
बताइए मैं देख रहा हूं फटाफट बताइए इतना
समझ में आ रहा है सबको आई एम सीइंग द
फोन एवरीवन प्लीज बता दीजिए जल्दी से समझ
में आ रहा है सबको इतना प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस यस ओके ओके ओके ओके
ओके गट इट गट इट सभी लोग
बताइए अरे देखते जाओ भाई लिंक्स क्या
देखना होगा देखते तो जाओ देखते तो जाओ अभी
अभी तो यार शुरू की है
कहानी
ओके सबका रिप्लाई आएगा तभी मैं और लाइक
मार दो यार लाइक मारे कि नहीं आपने अरे
यार 76 लोग देख रहे हैं 62 लाइक्स है यार
ये तो नाइंसाफी करते हो तुम लोग यार मेरे
साथ बहुत नाइंसाफी है मेरे साथ नाइंसाफी
कर रहे हो देख
लो अब देख लेते हैं कितने यूआरएल इसने
फाइंड किए कितने जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स
फाइंड किए डब्ल्यू सफन एल से यहां पे एक
बार देख लेते हैं कितने हैं वो सारे
जावास्क्रिप्ट जो इसने लिंक्स निकाले
जावास्क्रिप्ट के अ जो फाइल्स निकाले हैं
ये कितने हैं देख लेते
हैं ओ हो 221 22 जावा स्क्रिप्ट के फाइल
निकाल हैं भाई सब जस ने ये बहुत ही कमाल
की बात है अब यहां पे इसके कुछ और देख
लेते हैं यहां पे सिंपल फ्लैग है इसके हान
c कं करेंट वर्कर्स लगाने हैं यहां पे अ h
c से आप कंकर वर्कर्स लगा सकते हैं य आरएस
ठीक है टाइम आउट दे सकते हैं आप ठीक है अ
डिफॉल्ट 15 है काफी है यहां पे यूजर एजेंट
दे सकते हैं वर्जन दे सकते हैं चलो इसमें
क्या है ना क करेंट वर्कर्स को थोड़ा सा
लगा देते हैं एक बार काम करते हैं एक बार
सेम चीज में हम सब जीएस हमने किया है ना
इसमें हाइन सी कनकं वर्कर्स को 40 कर देते
हैं एंड देन अ हाइन t थ्रेड को हम 30 कर
देते हैं मान लो ऐसा करते हैं एंड देन
देखते हैं कितना हमें रिजल्ट मिलता है 221
ही मिलता है या ज्यादा मिलता है लेट्स सी
221 से मिला चलो ठीक है कनकं वर्कर्स को
हम यहां पे 50 कर देते हैं देखते हैं
रिजल्ट हमें सेम मिलता है या ज्यादा मिलता
है या कुछ कुछ अलग मिलता है देखते हैं 221
ही मिला बढ़िया कंकट वर्कर्स को यहां पे 9
टी कर देते हैं लेट्स सी आर वी गेटिंग सम
डिफरेंट रिजल्ट्स नहीं 221 ही मिल रहा है
चलिए थ्रेड को हम 30 ही रहने देते हैं
थ्रेड को तो क्या ही ज्यादा और क्या करें
इतना काफी है तो 221 रिजल्ट्स हमें ये
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है ये हमने कंफर्म कर
लिया चलिए बढ़िया तो एवरीथिंग वी कंफर्म्ड
खत्म हो गया सब जस्ट से हमने इतने फाइंड
किया अब हम क्या करेंगे हम इन सारे यूआरएल
को पहले एक तो फाइल में डाल दो भाई ठीक है
पहले एक फाइल में डाल दो सबसे पहले फाइल
में कैसे डाल दो भाई तो सब जस हमने ये
किया हम तो सिंपल भी ये काम चल ही रहा था
अब यहां पे इसको राइट ये आपने एडी यहां प
आउट कर दिया य अब इसको हम एक फाइल में डाल
देते हैं फाइल क्या डाल देते हैं
रैपिड रैपिड जेएस व ऐसे कर देते हैं रैपिड
जेएस व जेव हा राइट रैपिड जेएस व ठीक है
यह कर दिया एंड डॉट टी
एक्टी एक फाइल बना देते हैं सिंपल रैपिड
जव ये एक फाइल बना देते हैं चलिए हमने ये
फाइल बना दी अब यहां पे js1
एक्सटी इसमें डाल देते हैं जस्ट
वेट क्या हुआ भाई क्या दिक्कत आ रही है
बताइए कनकं वर्कर क्या है मतलब नंबर ऑफ
रिक्वेस्ट बोल दो नंबर ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट मतलब
कि कितने लोग एक बार में वह काम कर रहे
हैं वह ऑपरेशन कर रहे हैं बस यह चीज
है समझ में आ रहा है देख रहा हूं
मैं
अच्छा
ओके चलिए ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है गट
इट
वर्कर्स मतलब काम करने वाले ही हैं सिंपल
सा फंडा है ठीक है यहां पे हमें एलएस किया
एंड हमें क्या मिला व्हाट वी गॉट रैपिड
जस्ट 1tx हमें एक फाइल मिल गई
जावास्क्रिप्ट की अब हम यहां पे यूज करने
वाले हैं कटाना टूल को चलिए कटाना को यूज
कर लेते
हैं व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग
टू यूज कटाना तो चलिए कटाना के पेज पे
चलते हैं यहां पे इसको कैसे कंफिल करना है
कैसे इंस्टॉल करना है देख लेते हैं गो का
गो में रिटन टूल है तो सिंपली यहां पे
कमांड है कॉपी कर लीजिए यहां पे बहुत आसान
है एंड य बटू के लिए यहां पे स्पेशल दिया
हुआ है ये सारी चीजें चलो ठीक है ये हमें
जरूरत नहीं है गो का है डायरेक्टली
एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो गो का कुछ इस तरीके से
एंटर कीजिएगा यहां पे अ
लाइक अ कमांड डालिए और एंटर कीजिएगा ये
इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा मेरे पास ऑलरेडी ये शायद
इंस्टॉल होगी अ कटाना या इंस्टॉल है हान
कीजिएगा कटाना टूल जो है वो लॉन्च होके
यहां पे इस तरीके से आ जाएगी अब ये कटाना
से कैसे हम जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स
निकालेंगे ये हम देखते हैं ठीक है चलिए
इसमें दो चीज़ें हैं एक h u दीजिए एक
टारगेट यूआरएल दीजिए और वह उससे
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स को निकाल के आपको
देगा एंड यहां पे या तो आप हान लिस्ट देके
आप लिस्ट एक यूआरएल की दे सकते हैं जिसको
कि अह अ जिसको कि यह जहां से यह
जावास्क्रिप्ट निकाल के आपको प्रोवाइड
करेगा बट यह कैसे प्रोवाइड करेगा यह भी
जानना जरूरी है यह सारे लिंक्स प्रोवाइड
करेगा उसमें से आपको जावास्क्रिप्ट जो है
वह निकालना है एग अ फाइंड करना है अब यह
इसको हम थोड़ा सा इन एक्शन देख लेते हैं
पहले कटाना पे जब आप आप चलेंगे इसके पेज
पे यहां पे तो यूसेज में आप देख सकते हैं
कुछ इस तरीके के बहुत सारे इसके यूज केसेस
हैं यहां पे आप देखेंगे कटाना हाई फन य
एंड फिर जो डोमेन है वो आपको डोमेन देना
है एंड इस तरीके से आप मल्टीपल डोमेंस भी
दे सकते हैं हाई अ कॉमा दे दे के ठीक है
एंड कैट के साथ भी आप इसको पास आउट कर
सकते हैं ठीक है एंड लिस्ट में यूआरएल
लिस्ट अभ भी आप दे सकते हैं ठीक है दोनों
चीजें आप कर सकते हैं चलिए अब यहां पे हम
क्या कर देते हैं सिंपल क्या करते हैं
कटाना को यूज़ कर लेते हैं एक बार कैसे
यूज़ करेंगे पहले इसको देखते हैं हम सिंपल
क्या करते हैं ना पहले इसका आउटपुट को
देखते हैं तो कटाना यहां पे कर दिया h u
हम एक सिंपल यूआरएल देते हैं
rapid.com हाइ फन डी एंड डेप्थ को थोड़ा
सा इंक्रीज कर देते हैं फाइव कर देते हैं
डेप्थ को ठीक है डिफॉल्ट तीन है यहां पे
देन डेप्थ ऑफ क्रॉ ंग की बात हो रही है
यहां पे क्रॉल कितने डेप्थ तक क्रॉल ये कर
रहा है उसकी बात हो रही है देन वी आर
गोइंग टू एफसी हम ठीक है कॉन्फिन फाइल
वगैरह अभी कुछ यूज नहीं कर रहे
हैं चलिए
दैट्ची देखते हैं क्या होता है कटाना इज
स्टार्टिंग एंड लेट्स सी अब ये कटाना क्या
करेगा जितने भी यूआरएल हैं उस पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन के वो आपको फेच करेगा ठीक है जितने
भी यूआरएल है सबको फेच करेगा देखिए ये
मल्टीपल यूआरएल फेच कर रहा है देखते जाइए
देखते अभी इसमें बहुत कुछ करेंगे अभी
देखते जाइए क्या करेंगे सब आपको मैं समझाऊ
ये सबको दिख रहा है इसमें तो अभी ऑटोमेशन
भी होगा बहुत कुछ होगा बस बने रहिए मजे
लेते रहिए आज के सेशन
का ठीक है वी आर ट्राइट नमरे
जावास्क्रिप्ट लेट्स सी वी आर फाइंग टू
इरेट चैट में तहलका मचा रहे हो भाई
एसटीडीपी एकस इंपोर्ट एरर आ रहा है सर्च
मारो एरर सर कंकट समझ नहीं आया भैया कंकट
वर्कर मतलब आप जैसे 10 लोग और हैं दे आर
ट्राइज में आ रहा है दे आर वर्किंग ऑन योर
बिहा ठीक है देखिए यह बहुत सारे लिंक्स को
फैच कर रहा है उस पर्टिकुलर एक डोमेन
मैंने दिया अभी रड नेट सोचो जब इसको मैं
मल्टीपल डोमेन दूंगा तो यह कितने सारी
फाइल्स को फेच करेगा चलिए यह तो ठीक है
अभी पहले देखते जाइए
अभी यह तो सारे डोमेंस प्रोवाइड कर रहा है
ठीक है डॉट जेएस वाले भी और नॉर्मल जो
डोमस है वो भी प्रोवाइड कर रहा है अब इस
टूल में क्या हम करेंगे हमें सारे डोमस
थोड़ी ना चाहिए हमें क्या चाहिए हमने d5
कर दिया हमने इसको डीडी हान डी हटा देते
हैं थ ही रहने देते हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट जो
होता है रड नेट से अब हमें देखो अब हमें
क्या चाहिए मुझे बताइए हमें क्या चाहिए
हमें चाहिए कि सिर्फ हम जावास्क्रिप्ट
हंटिंग कर करे जावास्क्रिप्ट क्रॉ करें तो
हान जेसी लगा देंगे क्या करेंगे भैया हाइन
जेसी लगा देंगे करके एंटर मारेंगे अब
देखिए क्या होता है लेट्स सी अब देखिए अब
यह जो आपको रिजल्ट्स दे रहा है ये यह
मोस्टली आपको जो जेएस वाली रिजल्ट्स है वो
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है देखते जाइए जेएस वाली
देखिए हमने हान जेसी लगाया अब ये जेएस
वाली रिजल्ट्स जो है आपको ये प्रोवाइड कर
रहा है देखते जाइए देखते जाइए देख रहे हैं
यह जेएस वाले रिजल्ट्स आपको दे रहा है जो
भी रिजल्ट्स है आप को ये सारे
जावास्क्रिप्ट के दे रहा है ठीक
है जेएस फाइल ओनली हां जी हां जी हां जी
सर एटीटीपी एक इंपोर्ट एरर भाई बता अरे
यार इंपोर्ट एरर सर सॉल्व करो ना एरर को
खुद से सॉल्व करो ना बहुत आसान है
भाई बिल्कुल सही गर्वित वर्मा नंबर ऑफ
वर्कर्स ज्यादा हुए तो काम जल्दी होगा
फास्ट होगा सही बात है बिल्कुल
सही यह सारे जेस वाले आपके मिल रहे हैं
ठीक है आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे जेएस
जेएस वाले आ रहे हैं बट अब इसमें भी कुछ
चीजें हैं जो अभी मैं बात करूंगा अभी आपसे
रुक जाइए
ठीक है यह तो रिजल्ट्स आपको आ रहे है चलिए
ऐसे रिजल्ट्स बहुत सारे आएंगे अभी हम इसको
क्लोज कर देते हैं अब हमने क्या किया हमने
जावास्क्रिप्ट कॉलिंग की अब इसमें अब
इसमें क्या होगा हमने जेसी तो लगा दिया
जावास्क्रिप्ट कॉलिंग के लिए बट जब तुम ये
कॉलिंग कर रहे होगे जावास्क्रिप्ट वाली तो
तुम एक चीज नोटिस करना कॉलिंग कर रहे हो
तो ये यह वाले लिंक्स भी इंक्लूड कर रहा
है ये देखो ना स्ल जेएस फ्रंट एंड ड्रॉप
डाउन ऐसे करके ये वाली जेएस को भी ये
कैप्चर कर ले रहा है मतलब कहने का सेंस ये
है ये हमारा एंड पॉइंट नहीं है हमें एंड
पॉइंट वाले जो जाड जस वाले एंड पॉइंट वाले
हैं वही चाहिए तो इसमें हम थोड़ा सा और
मॉडिफिकेशन करेंगे क्या मॉडिफिकेशन करेंगे
आप अब इसमें से हम ग्रिप
करेंगे ग्रिप करेंगे क्या ग्रिप करेंगे
भैया
जेएस डॉट जेएस इसको हम ग्रेप करेंगे अब
इसको तो ग्रेप करेंगे डॉट जस लगा दिया
हमने बट हम इसमें एक वेरिएबल सिंबल देंगे
ताकि हमें एक पर्टिकुलर सिर्फ एंड पॉइंट
से ही मिले
दैट्ची उसकी लिस्ट आपको जावास्क्रिप्ट
वाली मिल जाएगी एंड यह काम करना अभी शुरू
कर चुका है एंड यह काम करता रहेगा कैसा लग
रहा है यह मजेदार लग रहा है जावास्क्रिप्ट
एन्यूमरेशन में और
बताइए मजे आ रहा है
भाई बहुत लोगों के दिमाग से उड़ रहा है
क्या दिमाग से नहीं उड़ना चाहिए भाई बहुत
आसान चीज है जावा मैंने आपको पहले ही
बताया कि हम क्या कर रहे हैं बस मैंने
आपको पहले ही बताया कि हम क्या कर रहे
हैं ये देखो सिर्फ और सिर्फ जावास्क्रिप्ट
आ रही है सिर्फ एक लिंक कि आ रही है भाई
अभी तो सब डोमेन पास ही नहीं किया अभी तो
सब डोमेन की लिस्ट कहां पास की इसमें सोचो
क्या
होगा जाने क्या होगा रा हमारे देखो
देखो अरे एक बार 80 लोग आते हैं एक बार 70
हो जाते हैं समझ में नहीं आता
यार
शांके ग्रेट शांके बढ़िया आपको अच्छा लगा
बश की
प्लेलिस्ट सब जस टूल आसान है बट सब जस
टूल्स जो है टूल वह ज्यादा आपको रिजल्ट
नहीं देगा जितना रिजल्ट आपको यह प्रोवाइड
करेगा सबजी टूल से हमें कितने मिले थे
जावास्क्रिप्ट 200 कुछ मिले थे रापिड नेट
के उतने ही उसी के मिले थे ना बस अभी
देखते
जाओ इसमें देखते जाओ
अभी
अभी तो ये निकाल ही रहा है भाई देख रहे हो
ना ये निकाल ही रहा
है सर जैसे आप पढ़ा रहे हो अभी तक किसी ने
नहीं पढ़ाया बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद भाई ऐसे
शब्दों के लिए ऐसे शब्द सुनके मन बहुत
तृप्त हो जाता है और और भी
बेहतरीन
चीजें कंटेंट लेकर आने का मन होता है थैंक
यू सो मच आप सबका आभार चलिए
अरे टूल तुम कोई सा भी यूज कर लो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है भाई मिस्टर रिसर्चर
तुम्हें जो भी टूल यूज करना है ना यू कैन
यूज दैट पर्टिकुलर टूल नॉट एन इशू ट शुड
बी ट शुड नॉट बी एन इशू
ओके वो आपकी मर्जी है भैया कोई सा भी टूल
यूज कीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं कोई टेंशन अभी
तो मैं मल्टीपल चीजें बताने वाला हूं
ऑटोमेशन ऑटोमेशन भी थोड़ा अभी देखेंगे
इसमें यार अभी तो देखेंगे देखते
जाओ इतने सब आप जेएस का एनालाइज करेंगे
एनालाइज करेंगे एनालाइज
करेंगे सर अ सर आई नो यू वेर लाइक्ड माय
पोस्ट ऑन लिंक न नेम दिव्यांश मिश्रा यस
दिव्यांश आई
रिमेंबर प्रिंट मजा आ रहा है ओ हो साइबर
अटक विद निखिल
जी अच्छा कुछ चुनिंदा नाम ही दिखते हैं
मुझे आपके यार चैट में बाकी लोगों के नाम
नहीं दिखते यार मुझे यार बाकी लोग कहां गए
हैं नाम दिखाओ यार अपने हेलो हाय तो कर लो
एक बार देख रहे हो ये लिंक्स अब ये लिंक्स
प देखो जैसे ये एक लिंक मिला जावा
स्क्रिप्ट का ठीक है अब मैं इस पर क्या
करूंगा कंट्रोल कंट्रोल क्लिक करूंगा अरे
रुक जा कंट्रोल क्लिक करूंगा ये लिंक खुल
जाएगा ये
देखो ये दिख रहा है तुम्हे ये लिंक खुल
गया अब इसमें बहुत सारी चीजें है यह तो
भाई अभी
तो ज्यादा कुछ नहीं है इसमें इसमें ज्यादा
कुछ नहीं है मिलेगी मिलेगी टेंशन नहीं है
और बहुत कुछ मिलेगा ये देखो वॉलेट वाला
कुछ मिला ओ हो यह तो कुछ कुछ नहीं है ड जस
अच्छा पेज ही फाइंड नहीं है इसमें कुछ ना
कुछ होगा देखो यह वॉलेट gts5 है ना यह पेज
नॉट फाउंड आ रहा है किसी रिपोर्टर ने सॉरी
किसी सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर ने इस पेज को
रिपोर्ट जरूर किया होगा अकॉर्डिंग टू मी
यहां कुछ कुछ ना कुछ
सेंसिटिव डाटा होगी इस जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल
के अंदर उसने रिपोर्ट किया इन्होंने उस
पेज को हटा दिया ट्स इट देख रहे हो लेट
gtj8
यह सब हटा दिए भाई इन्होंने वाह वाह वाह
देख रहे हो इसमें कुछ है क्या बहुत सारे
पेज को रिपोर्ट कर दिया पहले ही देख रहे
हो रिपोर्ट कर दिया
इनको सस पेजस आर रिपोर्टेड कुछ ना कुछ
मिला
भैया
लीजिए सर नाम दिखा दिया मजा आ रहा है अरे
डीजे डीजे क्या कर रहे हो
डीजे यह देखो जाओ स्कप फा यहां पर कुछ
है
नथिंग अभी तो बहुत सारे लिंक्स है यार
लिंक्स तो बहुत सारे अभी आने बाकी है देख
रहे हो ना अभी तो अभी तो आ ही रहे ये मतलब
कहने का सेंस कि कि आपके जावास्क्रिप्ट के
लिंक्स ये गैदर करे जितने भी लिंक्स हो
सकते हैं ये गैदर करके आपके सामने लाएगा
फिर हम बाद में उसमें बहुत कुछ खोजें
छेड़छाड़ करेंगे उसको पहले तो अब इतने
लिंक्स निकाल दिए इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता
हूं अब यहां पे हमने क्या किया ग्रेप किया
डॉट जेएस वाली को डॉट जेएस वाली को निका
लिया अब यहां हमने एक यूआरएल के लिए किया
एक पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल के लिए किया और कुछ
भी नहीं किया अब मुझे क्या करना है कटाना
का हेल्प फाइल देखना है क्या करना है भाई
कटाना का हेल्प फाइल देखना है क्यों देखना
है भैया क्योंकि मुझे चाहिए
क्या क्लियर कटाना हान h
मैं ऊपर चलता हूं अब हान लिस्ट एक लिस्ट
ऑफ यूआरएल के लिए तो चलिए सेम कमांड हम
डालते हैं यहां पे सेम कमांड रहेगा अब
यहां पे
[संगीत]
rapid.com कितना मतलब कितनी बड़ी ये अ
कितनी बड़ी चीज है अब इसके साथ आप एक और
चीज क्या कर सकते हो यहां पे ग्रेप यहां
पे पाइप दे दो और यहां पे यूनिक लगा दो
यूनिक एंड शॉर्ट कर दो इसको शॉर्ट करते
मतलब यूनिक वाले जो होंगे बस वही रहेंगे
बाकी सारी चीजें हट जाएंगी यहां पे ये
आपने काम कर दिया शॉर्ट कर दिया
दैट्ची भी सब डोमेंस हैं इसके अंदर
प्रेजेंट है सबको एक-एक करके क्रॉल करेगा
एंड आपको जो रिजल्ट्स है वो लाके देगा एंड
क्या फिल्टर आउट कर देगा डॉट जेएस वाली
फाइल्स जो भी जावास्क्रिप्ट की फाइल्स
होंगी वो निकाल के आपको देगा सिर्फ एक एक
डोमेन की बात नहीं है यहां पे अब यहां पर
ये सारे डोमस जो हमने पास आउट किए हैं वो
सारे डोमेंस की बात है भैया अब ये क्रॉल
कर रहा है एंड आपको रिजल्ट जो है वो
प्रोवाइड करेगा देखते जाइए स्टार्टेड
कॉलिंग स्टार्टेड कॉलिंग स्टार्टेड कॉलिंग
यह सारे डोमस पे या सब डोमस आप बोलो इस पर
क्रॉल करना स्टार्ट कर रहा है ये यह
देखिए न हमने लगाए नहीं ना ओके लेट्स सी
कटाना में नवी हमारा टैग है क्या देखने के
लिए देख सकते हैं क्या नवी तो होना तो
चाहिए नवी वर्वस तो होता ही यार नवी सब
में तो नवी है
हमारा ओके लेट्स वेट मैं कंट्रोल सी करता
हूं यहां पे एक बार हान व टैग लगा लेते
हैं शॉर्ट यूनिक भी कर सकते हैं फिलहाल के
लिए नहीं भी करोगे तो कोई बात नहीं यहां
पे बट ब फिलहाल हान व लगा देते हैं य प
लेट्स सी द
आउटपुट हां कटाना में एक और चीज है एक और
फ्लैग है आप इसको देखिए यहां पे ऊपर चलते
हैं ऊपर चलते हैं ऊपर चलते हैं ऊपर चलते
हैं वेयर इट इज वेर इट इज कहां गया भैया
यह हम यूज कर रहे हान जेसी जेस स्क्रॉल के
लिए एंड देन वी कैन
[संगीत]
यूज साइलेंट इसमें नहीं था क्या ओके ओके
ओके
आउटपुट ट ठीक है पल
ले
स्टोर क्रॉल शो ब्राउजर श क्रम न
न नहीं इस वाले में वो ऑप्शन नहीं
है ठीक है इस वाले में नहीं है चलिए वेट
करते हैं यहां पे स्टार्टड कॉलिंग हो रही
है यहां पे उसके बाद यह आपकी जावा
स्क्रिप्ट को फिच करके देगा याद रखिएगा य
तो बस अभी अभी कॉलिंग ही स्टार्ट कर रहा
हैय अभी अभी तो ये कॉलिंग स्टार्ट कर रहा
है य सार सब डोमस की बहुत सारे सब डोमस है
भाई मतलब आपको टाइम जो चाहिए जब आप देखो
आपको यह तो समझ में आ रहा है ना कि बग
बाउंट जब आप करोगे तो आपको टाइम और पेशेंस
की रिक्वायरमेंट है ये आपको पता चल रहा है
ना भाई टाइम एंड
पेशेंस साइलेंट है क्या लास्ट में क्या
बात है यार तुम लोग देख लेते हो यार मैं
देख नहीं पा रहा कहां है साइलेंट अरे हां
हां हां डिस्प्ले आउटपुट ओनली ये वाला लगा
सकते हो आप आउटपुट में हाइन साइलेंट ठीक
है हाइन साइलेंट आउटपुट
लेने के
लिए बहुत सारे सब डोमस हो जा रहे हैं बहुत
थोड़ा सा टाइम थोड़ा मतलब लग ही जाएगा
ओबवियसली ये देख रहे हो इतने सारे सब
डोमेंस है यहां
पे हम
हम
बिना पेशेंस और बिना टाइम के बग बाउंट अगर
आप सोच रहे करेंगे तो यह गलतफहमी है ऐसा
नहीं होता है बग बाउंट के लिए पेशेंस एंड
टाइम दोनों चाहिए
भैया दोनों ही चाहिए
राइट सिद्धांत सिंह एक एक बग आज निकाल ही
दो सर अरे मतलब बग क्या बग आपको आके
बोलेगा क्या कि मैं यहां पर हूं सर आ जाओ
निकाल फाइंड करना पड़ेगा ना फाइंड करते
रहो करते रहो मिलेगा भाई बग भी मिलेगा
वैलिड बग मिलेगा एकदम दिमाग हिलाने वाला
बग मिलेगा ठीक
है सबसे अच्छी बात सर आपकी यह है कि आप
लाइव रेकन करवाते हैं नहीं तो बाकी लोग
वीडियो में कट्स लगा के सीधा रिजल्ट्स
दिखा देते हैं बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बक बिल्कुल
इसलिए तो लाइव आता हूं मैं वीडियो रिकॉर्ड
भी कर सकता था मैं बट वीडियो जब रिकॉर्ड
होती है उस टाइम पे क्या होती है कुछ
चीजें स्किप हो जाती है कुछ चीजें पार्ट्स
को हटा हटा भी दी जाती है आपको पता नहीं
चल पाता है या आपको आईडिया भी लग जाता है
तो कोई ज्यादा फर्क उससे पड़ता नहीं है
एंड वो ऑथेंटिक नहीं लगता मुझे तो ट्स द
मेन थिंग ठीक है ये चीज है चलो ये यह तो
अपना काम कर रहा है ये तो अपना काम कर रहा
है पता एक और चीज मैं आपको बताऊं आप
लिंक्स कहां से गदर कर सकते हैं एक और
तरीका है वो भी मैं आपको बताऊंगा अभी आने
वाले टाइम अभी देखो ना आज बहुत कुछ पता है
या बहुत कुछ होने वाला है बहुत कुछ होने
वाला है आज सर कुछ क्वेश्चंस को लेकर बहुत
कंफ्यूज थे मैं आपकी क्लास देख के बहुत
सारे सॉल्व हो गए कसम से लव यू सर लव यू
टू ब्रदर थैंक यू
शैडो हैकर हैकर फीलिंग आ रही
है बताऊंगा अभी कैसे पता
चलेगा
बताऊंगा बताऊंगा
बताऊंगा
यह देख रहे हो आप बहुत सारे सबडस को पास
किया अब इसमें टाइम लगेगा अब हमें इतने सब
डोमेंस को थोड़ा सा कम कर देना चाहिए ना
सब डोमेंस को थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा कम कर
देना चाहिए
राइट क्या बोलती है पब्लिक बताइए सबमें को
थोड़ा कम करके तब करें क्योंकि काफी
ज्यादा समय लग रहा
है
हां काफी ज्यादा समय लग रहा है
ना अच्छा चलिए एक फाइल के कंटेंट को
एक फाइल के कंटेंट को दूसरे फाइल
में कैसे भेजते हैं आप बताइए मुझे जरा चैट
में कमांड बताइए जल्दी से एक फाइल के
कंटेंट को दूसरे फाइल में कैसे कॉपी करते
हैं कॉपी या मूव कर दो कॉपी कर दो मूव कर
दो जो भी आपकी मर्जी है कर दो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं बताइए
जरा जो सबसे देखते कौन सबसे पहले बताता है
और एकदम सही होना
चाहिए
ओके चल रहा है चल चल तो रहा ही है यार मैं
कहां रोक रहा हूं मैं तो चल ही रहा है
चलता चलता चलता
जाए एक फाइल के जैसे एक फाइल में सब डोमस
की लिस्ट है दूसरे फाइल में भी सब डोमस की
लिस्ट है मुझे दोनों को मर्ज करना
है मतलब इसके कंटेंट को उधर लेकर चला जाना
है
बताइए चलिए सीपी ठीक है एमवी ठीक है ठीक
है ठीक है ओके
बढ़िया यह आरम हान आरफ कर रहा है य देखो
यह य जोरो दिमाग
इसका ओ माय
गॉड अनू बिल्कुल बिल्कुल कर सकते हैं वो
भी
बिल्कुल कर सकते
हैं उसको रिमूव करना है पूरा हर एक
चीज नाउ आई थिंक इट विल स्टार्ट गिविंग यू
द जेएस फाइल्स
हमने सिंपली क्या किया लिस्ट में लिस्ट
में से जेसी को कर रहे जेसी कर रहे हैं हम
जावास्क्रिप्ट कॉलिंग कर रहे हैं जेएस को
हम ग्रैब कर रहे हैं यूनिक शॉट जो है भैया
उनको हम निकाल रहे हैं ठीक है ये क्या आ
रहा है इनवैलिड ऑप्शन हान नवी क्या है
ये ओके हमने पहले ी नहीं दिया यार हमने
शॉर्ट के बाद ी दे दिया ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं
कोई बात नहीं देख देखते हैं देखते हैं
लेट्स
सी काफी सारे बेसिकली काफी सारे आ गए ना
सब डोम इसलिए थोड़ा सा टाइम तो लेगा यार
इतने टाइम मतलब बहुत ज्यादा टाइम क्या दे
हम
चलिए
ओके ओके यहां पे
बेसिकली कुछ खास हमें मिला नहीं यहां पे
एंड यहां पर हमने कुछ गलत भी चीजें कर दी
थी हम यहां पे यह वाली जो चीज है हम यहां
पर पहले ना इसको थोड़ा सा कम कर लेते हैं
यार काफी ज्यादा है काफी ज्यादा कंटेंट
मतलब हमने काफी काफी ज्यादा यूआरएल पास कर
दिए इसको यहां पे काफी टाइम ले ले रहा है
यहां पे हमारा रड फाइल t एकटी जो है अगर
आप देखोगे रड फाल t एकटी यहां पे हम देखते
हैं ठीक है कट
rapid.com है इतने सब डोमेंस पे अगर हम
करेंगे तो काफी ज्यादा टाइम तो लगना ही
लगना है अब देखो दे जैसे मैं क्या करता
हूं मैं सेम कमांड करता हूं यहां पे ये
चीजें हटाइए आप यहां पे हटा देते हैं यहां
पे
एंड ट्स इट
कटाना लिस्ट नवी एंड ग्रब एंड लेट्स सी यह
देखिए अब यहां से यह हमने थोड़ा सा वहां
पर कुछ गलत कर दिया था कमांड में ट्स वाई
हमें वहां पर व जो जेस फाइल्स थी वो नहीं
मिल पा रही थी अब जो है आपको यहां पे
पर्टिकुलर जो जेस फाइल्स है सारी वो जेस
फाइल्स भी सारी मिल रही है ठीक है जो भी
जेस फाइल्स है आपकी यहां पर सारी मिल रही
है यह देख सकते हैं आप यह जो डॉट जस करके
आ रहा है यहां पर य डॉट जस करके आ रहा है
यह सारी आपकी आ रही है राइट ये देखिए आप
सबको दिख रहा है यहां पे डॉट जीएस अब इसको
आप एक एक फाइल में डाल सकते हैं वी कैन
मूव इट इनटू अ फाइल बट अगर ज्यादा वो
चीजें करनी है तो चलिए इसको फाइल में एक
बार डाल देते हैं एंड इसको हम कर देते हैं
शॉर्ट शॉर्ट कर देते
हैं यूनिक होने चाहिए यूनिक यूनिक हां चलो
इसमें यूनिक हम कर देते हैं पहले तो
शॉटिंग कर देते हैं शॉर्ट कर देते हैं एंड
इसको हम एक फाइल में डाल देते हैं फाइल का
नाम दे देते हैं
रैपिड जेस
टू जेस कटाना कटाना
ड ठीक है रड जस कटाना यह करके और एंटर
करते हैं ना लेटस
सी वट इ
हैपनिंग शटिंग वा वाली जो चीज है ना इसको
एक बार क्या एक काम करते हैं शॉर्ट को
शॉर्ट तो हम बाद में भी कर सकते हैं ना तो
हम एक काम करते हैं शॉर्ट अभी हटा देते
हैं यहां से एंड इसको हम क्या कर देते हैं
लेट्स कीप
इट लेट्स रिमूव
इट ठीक है एंड यहां पे कर देते हैं रड
कटाना . इसमें हम इसको भेजते हैं एंड वीवी
कर लेते हैं हान वर्वस आउटपुट भी देखते
हैं एंड देखते हैं फिर कितने यूआरएल जो है
ये लेकर आता है सो इट शुड बी गिविंग द
जेएस यूआरएल राइट नाउ
ओके चलिए देखिए यहां पर यह हो रही है
कॉलिंग कॉलिंग तो हो रही है बट आर वी
गेटिंग लिंक्स इन द फाइल लेट्स चेक कैट
एंड नहीं हमें को फाइल तो मिली नहीं फाइल
बनी है ना कैट रैपिड जे एस
कटाना ड एक्सटी ओके सो यस वी आर गेटिंग द
फाइल्स हियर बट यहां पे ओके यहां पर बहुत
सारे आ रहे हैं य पे बेकार के एंट्री आ
रही है यहां पे तो आर एम
रैपिड जस इसको रिमूव कर देते हैं एंड अगेन
यहां पर हम क्या कर देते हैं अन सेम फाइल
बनाएंगे हम यहां पर एंड यहां
पर
अब जो है नवी हटा देते
हैं ए यहां पर इसका फ्लैग एक यूज कर लेते
हैं कौन सा साइलेंट वाला कहां गया साइलेंट
हान साइलेंट वाला डिस्प्ले आउटपुट ओनली
ठीक है एंड
देन ट र रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांसस ठीक है स्टोर
ए स्टोर ठीक है
फाइन हमने हान दे दिया फाइल टू राट आउटपुट
टू ठीक
है ओ मिट र फ्रॉम जेसन वन जसन आउटपुट से
है ये
तो बाकी और भी चीजें हटा सकते हैं
क्या ओके लेट्स चेक हान साइलेंट कर देते
हैं हाइन साइलेंट एंड देन हम इसको मूव
करते हैं इस फाइल के अंदर में लेट्स सी आर
वी गेटिंग द मतलब हमें कुछ रिजल्ट्स मिल
रहे हैं या नहीं मिल रहे है चलिए देखते
हैं इसमें लेट्स सी व
रन अब यहां पर हमने हाई फन साइलेंट लगा
दिया है तो ओबवियसली यह डायरेक्टली सीधा
आपको रिजल्ट्स देगा तो आपको वेट करना
है क्लाउड में स्लो नहीं है भाई ये यह
बहुत सारे डोमस है इसलिए इतना टाइम ले रहा
है क्लाउड में स्लो नहीं है ठीक
है ये गलतफहमी है कि क्लाउड में स्लो है
ये चलिए आई थिंक काफी सारे रिजल्ट्स आ गए
होंगे मैं एलएस कर लेता हूं एंड यहां पे
कैट रैपिड कटाना रैपिड जेएस कटाना पे
देखते हैं कुछ आया कि नहीं अच्छा कुछ भी
नहीं आया यहां पर तो इट मींस इट मींस
लेट्स डू वन
थिंग हमें थोड़ा सा कम करना ही पड़ेगा यार
बहुत सारे सब डोमस आ जा रहे हैं अ लट ऑ लट
ऑफ सबड आ बहुत सारे सबड थोड़ा कम कर दे
क्या बता दीजिए आप लोग थोड़ा कम कर देते
हैं ना बहुत सारे सबमें बहुत ज्यादा है
इसमें तो इसमें से हम कम कर देते थोड़ा सा
डू वन थिंग एलस करते यहां पर एंड यहां पर
आपको दिख रहा होगा
रैपिड फाइनल एकटी इसको हम थोड़ा सा कम कर
देते हैं क्या कर देते
हैं विम रैपिड फाइनल डटी एंड लेट्स डू
समथिंग चलिए इसमें से हम क्या करते हैं
गाइस हम थोड़े से कम कर देते हैं जैसे कि
अब हम क्या करेंगे कैट ठीक है रैपिड फाइनल
डटी एंड यहां पे हम हेड स्टार्टिंग
के 20 ले लेते हैं स्टार्टिंग के 20 यह
वाले जो आपके सब डोमस ये वाले स्टार्टिंग
के 20 सब डोमस आ गए यहां पे 20 मेरे ख्याल
से बहुत है है
ना 50 लेते हैं 50 तो बहुत ज्यादा हो
जाएंगे यार 50 तो बहुत ज्यादा होते हैं
चलो एक काम करते हैं 25 कर लेते हैं 25 कर
लेते हैं ठीक है 25 ये मिल गया आपके पास
अब इसको हम सेव कर लेते हैं किसम कर लेते
हैं
रैपिड 25 टी एकटी ठीक है रप 25t एकटी में
इसको हम सेव कर लेते हैं एंड ट्स इट एलएस
करते हैं सॉरी हेड कमांड यूज किया मैंने
फिल्टर करने के लिए टॉप के 25 के ठीक है
तो रैपिड 25 आ चुकी है कैट रैपिड
25 एंड डल सफन एल ठीक है 25 यहां पे आ
चुके हैं अब हम इसको पास करेंगे कटाना में
सेम कमांड हम ला देते हैं कटाना की वेर इज
द सेम कमांड यह रहा सेम कमांड एंड इसमें
से हम बेसिकली साइलेंट को हटा ही देते
हैं अब यहां पर यह वाली चीज हटा देते
हैं
रैपिड एंड क्या नाम था इसका 25 रड 25 यह
वाली कमांड डाल देते हैं यहां पर एंड ट्स
इट एंड इनका आउटपुट फॉर्मेट यूज कर लेते
हैं रन स्टडी आउट यहां पर क्या है आउटपुट
हान ओ फाइल राइट आउटपुट ट ठीक है हान लगा
देंगे यहां
पर ठीक है हान देते य प हाइन ओ एंड य देते
रैपिड और यहां पर देते हैं
कटाना डटी
एक्सटी ठीक है रैपिड कटाना ड एक्सटी यह
वाला काम करते हैं और एंटर करते हैं लेटस
सी क्या हुआ
य नो सच फाइल और डायरेक्टरी
फिर दिक्कत क्या
है तो यह तो फाइल डायरेक्टरी बननी चाहिए
ना
यार व्ट इज द
इशू क्या प्रॉब्लम आ रही है बताइए जरा
फाइल डायरेक्टरी यहां पर क्यों बता रहा है
कि फाइल नो फाइल डायरेक्टरी रैपिड
कटाना
चलिए एक फाइल ऑलरेडी पड़ी हुई है रैपिड
जेस कटाना इसी में डाल देते
इसको रैपिड जस कटाना डटी इसमें डाल देते
हैं देन देखते हैं क्या
र ओके कैट रैपिड जेस
कटाना ड कुछ भी नहीं य पर सो व्ट इ
हैपनिंग प्रॉब्लम क्या आ रही है भैया यह
बताइए पहले हमने यहां पे कटाना में लिस्ट
डाला रड 25 जसी को ग्रेप कियाड जए को हान
ओ डाल रहे हैं एंड ओ में हम डाल रहे हैं
तो यहां कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा रिजल्ट अब
देखते हैं एंटर करके डायरेक्टली ओ हटा
के ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके यस यस यस ग्रेट
ग्रेट हम यहां पे एक मिस्टेक कर रहे हैं
एंड वो मिस्टेक क्या है हम यहां पे हान
ग्रेप पाइप के बाद ग्रेप कर रहे हैं यहां
पे इसके बाद लगा रहे हैं फिलहाल यहां पे
जो जेसी लगाया यहां पे हान नो करेंगे एंड
यहां पे देन रैपिड जेएस कटाना जए
txt.gz उसको बता रहे कि वो कुछ सेपरेट चीज
है इसलिए वो हमें रिजल्ट्स नहीं दे रहा था
अभी आपको रिजल्ट्स मिलने स्टार्ट हो गए
हैं राइट
चलिए अ थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक
यू हां हां राइट वही मिस्टेक हो रही थी
यही तो बात है ना यार जब लाइव करने का यही
मजा है कि कुछ गड़बड़ होती है तो फिर
बताने वाले भी रहते हैं व मिस्टेक कर रहे
थे हम वहां परर मि टाइपिंग मिस्टेक आगे
लगा रहे थे हम
मतलब चलिए यहां पर रिजल्ट हमें आ रहे
हैं आपको दिख रहा होगा जेएस
वाली यह देखो एक जेएस वाली फाइल मिली है
यहां पर इस तरीके की फाइल मिलती है इस तरह
की फाइल
मिली अब इसमें सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन खोजो
जैसे एडब्ल्यू एस कुछ है क्या ओहो एड्स
टोकन है क्या नहीं है टोकन खोज लो ऐसे ऐसे
देखो टोकन कितने मिले भैया 76 एक दो
तीन अभी तो इसको हम वो करेंगे ऑटोमेट
करेंगे अभी तो देखते
जाओ तो हमें अभी रिजल्ट्स मिले जा रहे है
मिले जा रहे
है थोड़ी देर और वेट करो लाइव का ये देखो
अभी ये सारे तुम्हें रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे है
अभी ये जावास्क्रिप्ट के फाइल्स मिल रहे
हैं आपको 25 डोमस है ले लेट्स गेट ऑल द
जावास्क्रिप्ट
लेट इट लेट इट गो लेट इट गो लेट इट गो लेट
इट गो लेट इट गो चलिए अभी चलने देते हैं
इसको चलने देते हैं चलने देते हैं
[संगीत]
भैया
सर यह रिकन हम
जेएस जेएस से अलग कौन-कौन सी
लैंग्वेज कर सकते हैं बेसिकली
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल जो होती है ना
जावास्क्रिप्ट की जो लिंक्स होते हैं जो
जो फाइल्स होती है उसके अंदर आपको
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन मिलने के चांसेस होते
हैं इसलिए हम जावास्क्रिप्ट रेक ऑन करते
हैं या जावास्क्रिप्ट हंटिंग करते हैं
इसलिए हम जावा स्क्रिप्ट की फाइल्स को
निकालते हैं अभी जो लास्ट तक नहीं रहेंगे
ना जो लास्ट तक नहीं रहेंगे उनको उनका एक
बहुत शानदार चीज मिस होगा अभी अभी हम जब
ऑटोमेशन करेंगे तो मतलब इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
मिस होगा भाई आपका याद रखिएगा तो लास्ट तक
आपको रहना
पड़ेगा
लेट्स सी लेट्स
सी यस यस यस यस
यस
ओके लेट इट
प्रोवाइड प्रोवाइड
द अरे यार कहां से आया यार क्या बोल रहे
हो ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल का
मतलब पता है ना क्या होता
है देखो यह सब वही लिंक्स है जो बैन बंद
कर दिए इन्होंने हटा दिए कुछ कुछ लिंक्स
इन्होंने अच्छे अच्छे लिंक्स जहां पर कुछ
ना कुछ इनको मतलब रिपोर्ट किया गया होगा
एंड दे हैव रिमूव्ड
चलिए अच्छी बात है नाइस
कटाना का यही तो कटाना की एक खासियत है यू
विल गेट अ लॉट लॉट लट लॉट ऑफ जीएस फाइल्स
काफी सारे फाइल्स आपको मिलेंगे कटाना के
थ्रू
यह कमांड हमने डाला है अगर आपको नहीं पता
तो कटाना हान लिस्ट रड जेसी हमने जेसी को
फिल्टर आउट किया एंड इसको हम सेव कर रहे
हैं इस फाइल में रड j कटना t एकटी फाइल
में हम सेव कर रहे हैं यहां पे एंड देन
उसपे हम ग्रेप कर रहे हैं एंड यह वाली जो
चीज है वोह चला रहे हैं ग्रेप करके हम
जावास्क्रिप्ट जो है वो फाइंड कर रहे हैं
जेस वाली जो भी फाइल्स है उनको हम फाइंड
कर रहे हैं ठीक
है इसमें जो आपको इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोजर के अंदर आप उसको रिपोर्ट कर
सकते हैं यू कैन रिपोर्ट इट न द
इंफॉर्मेशन
डिस्क्लोजर
जीटीएम बहुत सारा कीवर्ड है इसका जीटीएम
जो है ना इसमें बहुत सारे हैं ठीक है सो
ऑलमोस्ट डन लेट्स चेक कैट
एंड रैपिड जस कटाना डटी एक्सटी एंड यह
सारी आपकी जेस फाइल जो है आपके पास आ चुकी
है आ चुकी है क्या यह क्या यह क्या आया
हुआ है हमारे
पास व्हाट वी गट हमने हमारी हमारी पाथ
क्या थी यार अरे
यार हमारा पाथ क्या था
कैट रप लेट्स चेक द फाइल फाइल व्ट वाज आवर
पाथ कीवर्ड की लिस्ट
ओके कीवर्ड के लि ठीक है हमारा पाथ क्या
था भाई हमारा व्ट वास आवर पाथ यह पा तो
रैपिड जेस कटाना ही था
ना देन व्ट इ हैपनिंग कैट
रैपिड जेस कटाना ड एक्स
सॉरी व्ट इशू जीस फाइल्स आई है ना अच्छा
ओके
हां फिल्टर आउट तो कर सकते हैं वह कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है बट वी गट हाउ मेनी
लिंक्स वी गट हियर लेट्स
चेक डब्लू सी हा
फनल 71 71 अब बेसिकली यहां वैसे तो हम
फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है यहां से हम ग्रिप लगा देंगे एंड यहां
से भी हम डॉट जस डॉट जस जो हमारी
फिल्टरिंग है हम इसको यूज कर लेंगे एंड वी
विल गेट द लि एंड डब्लू सफन एल करके देते
हैं कितने लिंक्स है 157 157 जेएस फाइल्स
वी हैव 157 ठीक
है सर उसी में डॉट जीएस फाइल भी है क्या
हां हां ड जए फाइल मिल गई मिल गई मिल गई ड
जस फाइल मिल गई हमारे पास तो वी हैव दिस
जेएस फाइल कितने 157 जेएस फाइल्स है आप
इसको निकाल सकते हैं अलग रख सकते हैं एंड
हमारे पास आ जाएगा ये जेएस फाइल ठीक है
157 तो चलिए मान लो मान लो 157 जेएस
फाइल्स हमारे पास आ चुकी है निकल के अब हम
क्या कर देते हैं इसको लेट्स मूव टू अ
डिफरेंट फाइल ऐसे कर लिया हमने एंड जेएस
एंड इसको मूव कर लेते
हैं
रैपिड js2 एकटी में ठीक
है ठीक है रैपिड टू js2 हमने इसमें मूव कर
लिया एंड वी हैव नाउ कट रापिड
js2 डटी
डब्लू सी हा फनल 157 चलिए अब रैपिड अब
मुझे बताइए हमारे पास दो फाइल्स है रैपिड
जस व रैपिड जस 2 एक्टी दो फाइल्स है इन
दोनों को मुझे मर्ज करना है कैसे करेंगे
जल्दी बताइए जल्दी बताइए मर्ज करना है भाई
देखलो रैपिड जस व में कितने
रैपिड जेस
व डब् सीफन
एल ड एक्सटी 221 इसमें है 157 उसमें है
मर्ज करना है बताइए
जल्दी व्हाट कमांड आई शुड यूज देखते हैं
आप लोग ही बताइए कौन सा कमांड यूज करूं
मैं जल्दी बताइए जल्दी फटाफट
प्लीज प्लीज टेल मी फास्ट
गाइस अपेंड अ न्यू अन यू अनयू ठीक
है अपेंड अनयू अनयू अनयू अनयू ठीक है अ
नयू कमांड यह कमांड यह
कमांड
कैट अच्छा अन्यू कमांड मैंने आपको बताया
था क्या मुझे याद क्यों नहीं आ रहा हां
मैंने बताया था शायद अनयू कमांड इसलिए आप
लोग अनय अनयू कर रहे हैं वही मैं सोच रहा
हूं अनयू क्यों बोल रहे हैं आप लोग
ठीक
है ठीक है अब एक काम करते हैं गाइस एक काम
करते हैं जैसा आपने बोला पहले मैं सीपी
कमांड यूज कर लेता हूं जैसा आप बोल रहे
हैं ठीक
है ठीक है मैं पहले सीपी कमांड यूज कर रहा
हूं आपने बहुत लोगों ने सीपी बोला है तो
सीपी मैं करता हूं यहां पर रैपिड जेस व कर
देता हूं मैं रैपिड
जव ठीक
है एंड रैपिड जैसा आपने बता रहे वैसे मैं
लिख रहा हूं जेएस 2 एक्सटी एंड आप बोल रहे
हैं कि रैपिड जेएस व जेटू कर दीजिए क्या
बोला एकने एंड देन इसको अलग फाइल में डाल
दीजिए
रैपिड जेएस 3 इस तरह से आपने बोला हुआ है
डटी एकटी यह वाला रड जस 3t एक्टी यह कमांड
सक्सेसफुल होगा या नहीं
बताइए यह बताइए यह कमांड हमारा वह काम
करेगा कि नहीं जो हम करना चाह रहे
हैं बताइए
जल्दी रिचार्ज खत्म होने वाला है रिचार्ज
कर दो ठीक है मैं अभी कर देता हूं आपका
रिचार्ज जस्ट एक सेकंड रुक जाइए आपका
रिचार्ज मैं अभी करता हूं प्लीज वेट अ कौन
है जिनका रिचार्ज शायद खत्म हो गया है
अ किसी का रिचार्ज खत्म हुआ है मैं
रिचार्ज कर देता हूं एक बार होगा नोप नोप
नोप नोप नोप नोप पहले मैं इनका रिचार्ज कर
दूं पहले एक सेकंड के लिए वेट
कीजिए बीटीएस अच्छा इनको शायद टाइम टाइम
आउट पर डाल दिया ऑलरेडी गर्वित ने बढ़िया
चलिए डोंट नो एक बार करके देखते हैं ना
करके एंटर करते हैं देखिए एंटर किया हमने
सब कुछ हो गया अब कैट करते हैं रैपिड जस
डटी एक्सटी करते हैं रैपिड जस 3t एक्सटी
एंड इसमें वर्ड काउंट ले लेते हैं डब्लू
सी हाइन एल अब देखिए यहां पे क्या आया कुछ
भी तो नहीं आया आया भाई क्या आया कुछ भी
तो नहीं आया हां कुछ भी नहीं आया चलिए अब
एक काम कर लेते हैं जो जो बोल रहे सब
करेंगे अभी देखते
जाओ हा अब क्या
था कैट य कैट का क्या दे रहे
हैं
अपेंड अन्यू चलो अन्यू कर लेते हैं अनू
अन्यू ऑलरेडी यहां पर नहीं मिलेगा आपको
इंस्टॉल करना पड़ेगा तो अन्यू को पहले हम
इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं अनू का यूज बोल रहे
हैं करने के लिए चलिए अनू इंस्टॉल कर लेते
हैं अन्यू गिट हब लेट्स टेक द अन्यू कमांड
चलिए इसका आपका यह भी कर लेते हैं ये ये
जिन्होंने क्लास अटेंड करी थी वो शायद
जिन्होंने भी क्लास अटेंड करी थी ट्स वई
दे आर सेइंग दिस कमांड राइट अ न्यू कमांड
चलिए अच्छी बात है अगर आप याद है कुछ तो
ट्स अ ग्रेट थिंग इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं गो
इंस्टॉल है इसको सिंपल यहां से इंस्टॉल कर
लेते हैं
ठीक है लेट ट इंस्टॉल उसके बाद क्या करना
है
[संगीत]
हमें हो गया इंस्टॉल हो गया न यू यह वाला
आपको चलाना है तो अब क्या करते हैं
कैट क्या अब अनू वाली कमांड क्या डालना है
चलिए बताइए अनू का कमांड बता दए जल्दी से
क्या डाले अन का कमांड कमांड बताइए पूरा
दोनों के लिए यह दोनों फाइल्स है यह दोनों
फाइल्स ड जस व रैपिड जस टू अब बताइए
मुझे
कैट कैट रैपिड
जस सॉरी रैपिड जेएस व उसके बाद रैपिड
जेस
डटी ठीक है उसके बाद क्या करना है बताइए
[संगीत]
जल्दी उसके बाद अनू लगा दू ना ऐसे अनू ऐसे
कर
दू एंटर कर देते हैं और इसकी वड काउंट देख
लेते हैं चलो जिसने भी बताया है चलो वर्ड
काउंट करते हैं
121 121 आ रही है वड काउंट तो भाई अब बताओ
मुझे 121 आ रही
है कैट के साथ पास किया 121 आ रही है इसकी
वड काउंट अब बताओ
मुझे तो 121 आ रही है क्या भाई कहां हो
तुम यह तुम देख देख यार 200 200 तो उसी के
थे 300 300 टोटल टोटल 300 कुछ होने चाहिए
ना यह देखो यार तुम लोग भी ना
भाई . डबल सफन
एल 442 आने चाहिए टोटल
442 शॉर्ट शॉट शॉट अरे रे रे रे रे रे एक
कमांड नहीं पता है भाई एक कमांड याद नहीं
है आप लोगों को आप लोगों को एक कमांड
मैंने बताई थी मैंने आप लोगों को बताया था
इसलिए यह पूछ क्यों रहा हूं मैं यह बताइए
अन्यू हाइन क्या बोल रहे हो भाई कोई एक
प्रॉपर कमांड नहीं बता पा रहा है एक बंदा
भी आप में से यह क्या बता रहा है भाई कैट
ऐसा बोल रहा हूं मैं ठीक है हां ठीक है
फिर क्या हुआ अब बताओ एक भी यहां
देखो इको
फाइल यह देखो यहां पर पहली
चीज अरे
अरेरेरे यह देखो यहां पे अन्यू को यूज
कैसे करना है अपेंड लाइंस फ्रॉम एसटीडी इन
टू अ फाइल ठीक है बट ओनली इफ दे डोंट
अपीयर इन द फाइल समझ में आ रहा
है क्या मैंने बताया
था कैट फाइल वन अन्यू फाइल
टू ठीक है चलिए यह वाला काम कर लेते हैं
कैट एंड रैपिड जेएस
1t अ न्यू एंड रैपिड ज
एक्टी कुछ इस तरीके से आप बोल रहे हैं
एंटर कर दिया हमने बढ़िया हमने एंटर कर
दिया अब यहां पर क्या करना है हमें अब हम
यहां पर चेक कर लेते हैं एक बार लेट्स चेक
कैट रैपिड
ज2 ड्ड सफन एल एंड यहां पर
221 यहां पर 221 ही है भैया अब
बताइए अरे वो तो मैनुअली सब हो जाएगा भाई
पहले तुम लोग तो
बताओ हेल्प क्या यहां तो हेल्प मेनू है
बताओ यहां से देख के बताओ चलो बताओ यहां
पे ये रही हेल्प मेन्यू बताओ अब बताओ बोलो
जल्दी अब
बोलो गर्वित ने बोला है कैट वन टू मस्ट
डटी
एक्सटी क्या बोल रहे हो
गर्वित अभी वही अभी यही काम किया था
भाई यही तो किया था ड एक्स वाला भाई अभी
क्या किया था थोड़ी देर पहले चलो कैट वाला
कर लेते हैं चलो चलो कैट का कर लेते हैं
जैसा गर्वित बोल रहा है वैसे कर लेते हैं
गवित वाली काम कर लेते चलिए हा गर्वित
वाला काम कर लेते हैं यह वाला काम नहीं
किया था हमने रैपिड जेस वड
एक्सटी रैपिड जस ड एक्सटी एंड देन इसको ले
जाते हैं कहां पर इसको ले जाते हैं रैपिड
जेएस
[संगीत]
5xt 3 कर देते हैं थ रैपिड जस फाइनल t
एक्टी कर देते हैं फाइनल एकटी रैपिड ज फल
ठीक है अब इसको देख लेते हैं रैपिड जस
फाइनल डटी कोई नहीं बता पाया भाई कोई नहीं
बता पाया सिर्फ और सिर्फ गर्वित ने सही
आंसर किया वह भी जनरिक वे में उसने जो सही
आंसर किया वो वाला आंसर किया रैपिड जस
फाइनल ड एकटी यहां पे कैट कमांड का यूज
करके किसी ने भी किसी ने भी नर्मल नॉर्मल
सी चीज को नॉर्मल सी एक चीज थी उसको बता
नहीं पाए आप लोग एंड इसलिए मैं आपको बोलता
हूं जब आप सेशन को ध्यान से देखेंगे तभी
आपको हर चीज समझ में आएगा प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे तब समझ में आएगा ये एक जनरिक वे
में इसने बताया कैट रैपिड जैसे एक दो
फाइल्स है रीड किया और उसमें से एक तीसरे
फाइल में डाल दिया सिंपल सा फंडा है ये तो
बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा हो गया ठीक है अब
इसमें और भी ए न्यू कमांड का अगर हम यूज
करेंगे यहां पे यहां आप देख सकते हैं
एन्यू कमांड का भी यूज हम करेंगे क्या
करेंगे देखो हियर इज़ अ फाइल कॉल्ड .
txt.gz
मान लो यहां पे कैट और यहां पे कर देते
हैं अब रैपिड जे रैपिड
जेएस एंड टू वाले को ड एकस ठीक है अब यहां
पे किया अन्यू लगा दिया अन्यू अब यहां पे
क्या करेंगे रैपिड जस
2t यहां पे टू के जगह प अब यहां पे वन कर
देंगे . एक्टी यह काम हो गया बस इतना हमने
किया एंड अब हम यहां पर एंटर करते हैं अब
एंटर करने के बाद अब क्या करते हैं कौन सा
किस में गया भैया इ यूज टू अपेंड लेटर टू
थड यानी कि पहले वाले में लेटर वाले को
अपेंड कर देगा तो अब कर देते हैं कट रैपिड
जस डटी एकड सन एल अब एंटर करेंगे यहां पर
221 अब इसलिए यह हो रहा है मैं आपको यह
चीज समझा देता हूं क्योंकि यह सेम सब डोम
सेम डोमेंस को सेम लिस्ट को कंटेन करता है
जैसे अगर मैं यहां पर आपको दिखाऊं कैट
रैपिड जस फाइनल डटी एक्सटी और आपको यहां
पर मैं दिखाऊं डब्लू सई फनल 442 है अब
इसमें से क्या कर देते हैं अब इसमें से
देखो क्या करते
हैं
शॉर्ट
यूनिक जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट
वेट अब यहां पर क्या कर इसको शॉर्ट कर
देते हैं सॉरी इसको शॉर्ट कर देते हैं एंड
यहां
पर
यूनिक यूनिक कर देते हैं डब्लू सई फनल अब
देखिए 121 समझ में आ रहा है 121 यहां पर
यूनिक जो लिस्ट आ रही है आपकी 121 ही आ
रही है यानी हमारे पास इतने ही यूनिक
लिस्ट
है बस ट्स इट यह हमारी यूनिक लिस्ट है 121
इतना समझ में आ रहा
है यह समझ में आ रहा
है बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही अब बिल्कुल
सही है गर्वित तुम्हारा बिल्कुल सही अभी
जो तुमने किया कैट वाला अन्यू के साथ
बिल्कुल सही है तो अब हमारे पास यूनिक
रिजल्ट जो आ रहे हैं 121 हमारे पास शॉर्ट
किया हमने जो भी हमारे पास फाइनल आई है वह
फाइनल आपकी रिजल्ट्स जो आई थी टोटल जो
आपने किया हुआ था 442 यह आ गई हमारी उससे
हमने यूनिक कर दिया एंड उसको हमने निकाला
तो हमारे
पास
121 अरे एन जो है ना एन देखो क्या करता है
देखो तुम लोग समझ नहीं पा रहे हो और मैं
बिना समझाए मानूंगा नहीं तो देखो अब समझो
पहले हां हां हां हां हा हा देखो अभी मैं
आपको मैं समझा देता हूं एक बार आप लोग ो
समझिए
प्लीज ठीक है यह
समझिए अपें लाइंस फ्रॉम स्टडी इन टू फाइल
ठीक है बट ओनली इफ दे डोंट अपीयर इन द
फाइल
बस ओनली तभी अभी एक काम करते हैं इसको मैं
एक चेक करके तुम्हें दिखा देता हूं रड फइल
है ना शॉर्ट यूनिक जो है ना यूनिक यहां पे
हान डी दे देता हूं यहां पे
अ शो नहीं किया
क्या ओके ये कमांड नहीं था शॉर्ट ये रहा
यूनिक एंड हाइन डी कर देते हैं इसको ठीक
है हाइन
121 अब यहां पर क्या करते हैं डी जीरो ओके
ओके हान डी
सॉरी हान डी डुप्लीकेट्स के लिए यहां पे
हान डी 121 अब यूनिक का मैं तुम्हें
दिखाता हूं यहां पे यिक हाइन h ले
लो यूनिक हाइन एफन हेल्प ले लो यहां पे आ
जाओ ऊपर चलते हैं यहां पे यह रहा यिक हान
एफन हेल्प ठीक है अब यहां प देखो हाइन डी
रिपीटेड ओनली प्रिंट डुप्लीकेट लाइंस वन
फॉर ईच ग्रुप ठीक है तो हान डी जब तुम
लगाओगे तो ये ओनली प्रिंट डुप्लीकेट लाइंस
सबके लिए डुप्लीकेट लाइंस आपको ये प्रिंट
करके दे देगा एंड प्रिंट ऑल डुप्लीकेट
लाइंस के लिए हान डी कैपिटल डी लगा दोगे
तो ठीक है रिपीटेड के लिए हान डी तो अब
यहां पे मान लो मुझे एक रिपीटेड लाइन मैं
तुमको दिखा देता हूं यहां
पे ये फाइनल
आया यह फाइनल है लिस्ट ठीक है अब इसमें से
भी मैं एक काम कर देता हूं मैं तुम लोगों
के लिए बहुत सस्ता आसान काम कर देता हूं
यहां पे दो फाइल्स है पहले तो मैं सारे
फाइल्स रिमूव करता हूं जो जो फ फाइल्स है
रैपिड 25 यह रहने देते हैं रैपिड जस व है
रैपिड जस ट है एंड रैपिड जस 3 हटा देते
हैं रैपिड जस 3 हटा देते हैं एंड रैपिड
जेस
फाइनल यह भी हटा देते हैं ठीक है जेस
फाइनल वाला हटा देते हैं रैपिड जेस थ हटा
देते हैं एक फाइव भी था क्या नहीं फाइनल
ये दोनों हटा देते हैं ठीक है अब हमारे
पास फाइनल हो गया रैपिड जस वन है रेपिड जस
टू है एक 25 वाली जो है वो तो सब डोमस की
थी रैपिड फाइनल डटी जो थी वो तो फाइनल थी
रैपिड कटाना वाला जिसमें कि हमारे पास
जावास्क्रिप्ट के फाइल्स थे ठीक है अब ये
दो है मान लो अब
कैट रैपिड
js1 यह देखो js1 एक्टी उसके बाद रैपिड
js2 यह तुम्हें पता चल गया अब इसमें हम
क्या करते हैं यहां पे कैट नहीं करते यहां
प हम शॉर्ट कमांड यूज करते हैं शॉर्ट
कमांड ठीक है शॉर्ट और यहां पे अब हम कर
देते हैं
यूनिक एंड नडी डी प्रिंट करेगा तो यह जो
है ना यह सारे डुप्लीकेट जो फाइल्स है
डुप्लीकेट जो भी यूआरएल डुप्लीकेट वो इसने
लिस्ट कर दिए कितने डुप्लीकेट यूआरएल है
भैया देख लीजिए डब्लू सीफन एल 121
डुप्लीकेट है टोटल टोटल 121 डुप्लीकेट है
समझ में आ रहा है और कितने इन दोनों में
फाइल्स है यह देख
लीजिए 442 तो 442 माइ 121 कर लीजिए कितने
बचेंगे 442 -
1202 ये
भी ये देखो 442 माइ 1 21 टोटल 321 यहां पे
आपके बेसिकली जो फाइल्स हैं वो आपके बच
रहे हैं 321 फाइल्स आर लेफ्ट हियर ठीक है
डुप्लीकेट्स को हटा देते हैं तो 442 में
से ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है समझ में आ रहा
है सबको
यर सभी लोग समझ में आ रहा है बताइए
जल्दी प्लीज बताइए मुझे इतना समझ में आ
रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा है
बताइए देन हम आगे
बढ़ेंगे 442 में से 121 हटा
दो 321
आया 321
आया ठीक
है ठीक है अब यहां पर तुम्हे समझ में आ
गया कि हमने यहां पे शॉटिंग कर दी रैपिड
js1 ज 2tx की यहां पे हमने शॉटिंग कर दी
हमने यहां पे लिस्ट दिखा दी चलो अब यहां
पे हम यहां पे इसको बंद कर देते हैं हो
गया इतना काम खत्म शॉर्ट कर दिया हमने अब
अब हम यहां पे क्या करना है हमें क्या
करना है इन दोनों को इन दोनों को कंबाइन
करके कंबाइन लिस्ट निकालनी है इन दोनों की
एंड उसमें से डुप्लीकेट्स को हटा देना है
तो चलिए बढ़िया है अब यहां पे हम क्या
करेंगे हम क्या करेंगे हमें कंबाइन लिस्ट
निकालनी है तो अब हम इसको क्या करेंगे
चलिए देखिए
कैट ठीक है रैपिड
जव यहां पर शॉर्ट कमांड यूज कर लेते हैं
रैपिड जस
व रैपिड जस ड
एक्स ठीक है इतना तो समझ में आ गया अब
यहां
पर
यूनिक यूनिक वाले निकाल लेते हैं इसमें से
जो भी हमारे यूनिक चीज हैं उसको हम निकाल
लेते हैं नडी से आप प्रिंट कर दीजिएगा
बाकी यूनिक कर लेते हैं एंड इसको हम डाल
देते हैं एक दूसरे फाइल में इसको हम दूसरे
फाइल में ले जाते हैं रैपिड अ रैपिड
यिक txt.gz
2 कर दिया यूनिक कर दिया इस पर एंड हम अब
इसको यिक डटी में डाल देते हैं और
कैट रड यिक t एकटी को हम एक बार देखते हैं
यहां पे ऐड आ चुका है थोड़ा वेट करता हूं
एंड यहां पे अब देखते हैं यहां पे ठीक है
यह सारी लिस्ट हमारे पास आ चुकी भैया जो
भी लिस्ट आनी चाहिए हमारे पास यह लिस्ट आ
चुकी है अब यहां पे कैट करते हैं एंड यहां
पे डब्लू सफन एल करते हैं और यहां पे 121
डोमस यहां प मिल रहे हैं अब देखो यहां पे
121 डोमस मिल रहे हैं यहां पे जो हमारे
पास
बेसिकली
यूनिक वाले डोमेन है जो आपके पास यूनिक है
अब यहां पर यूनिक को ही हमें थोड़ना हमें
यहां पर यहां पर यूनिक वाली डोमस आपको मिल
गई ठीक है अब यहां पर क्या बोल रहे
हो शॉर्ट हाइन य क्या बोल रहे हो
यार हाई फन
यू यस ठीक
है ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पर एक काम कर देते
हैं हम क्या कर लेते
हैं
शॉर्ट चलिए हान एक बार यूनिक कर देते हैं
यहां पर एंड यहां पर रैपिड जेस वन कर देते
हैं रैपिड जेस टू कर देते हैं एंड इसको हम
र पिड
जेस
रैपिड कौन सा था यूनिक यूनिकस इसको कर
देते नो सच फाइल और डायरेक्टरी ऐसा क्यों
भाई
ओके रैपिड
यूनिक ऐसा क्यों
भाई व्हाट इज
दिस सर आई हैव टेकन मेंबरशिप ओनली फॉर
थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू
थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू
ब्रदर चलिए एक काम करते हैं इसको लेट्स डू
वन थिंग
लेट्स डू वन थिंग गाइस डटी अच्छा डॉटी
एक्सटी नहीं लगाया था
क्या लगाया तो है
यार अच्छा अच्छा पहला वाला में ड लगाया
ओके ओके ओके सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी
पहले वाले में ड नहीं लगाया अब यहां प आ
चुका है य प एलस करते हैं कैट रैपिड यिक
एक्ड सफन ए एंड यहां प 121 यहां प आपके
पास पास यूनिक आ रहे है ये बेसिकली यूनिक
बाकी जो डुप्लीकेट्स है ये इसने हटा दिया
डुप्लीकेट्स को ठीक है अब ये 121 जो आ रहा
है टोटल अपना कितना था 400 कुछ था
ना 400 कुछ था ना यहां
पे देखो जब हमने यह वाला काम किया था मैं
दिखा देता हूं यह वाला यूनिक
वाला यहां पे यूनिक वाला जब हमने कमांड
चलाया था यूनिक वाली इसमें से हान डी जब
किया था डब्लू सफन एल देखा था तो हमें 121
यहां पर मिले हुए थे डुप्लीकेट्स के लिस्ट
जो है वो मिले हुए थे एंड यहां पर अगर यह
वाली की थी 121 ठीक
है कौन सा मैं समझा नहीं
यार क्या बोल रहे हो देखो देखो नहीं यार
देखो तुम लोग तुम लोग शायद क्लियर नहीं हो
पा रहे हो देखो यहां पे दो फाइल्स है यहां
पे ठीक है मैं पहले इसको रिमूव करता हूं r
एक् ये हमने कर दिया और इसको एक तीसरे
फाइल में डाल देते हैं
रैपिड
3 रड
जए 3t एकटी ये हमने डाल दिया चलो यह तो
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा सिंपल सा फंडा है
अब यहां पे कैट करेंगे यहां पे रड j3
एक्टी करेंगे डल सफन l करेंगे एंड आपको
442 डोमेंस मिल रहे हैं अब इस पर सिंपली
क्या करेंगे ना शॉटिंग य शॉटिंग चला देंगे
बस और कुछ नहीं करना है बस सिंपल सा फंडा
है यार शॉटिंग कैसे चलाना है देख लो यहां
पर शॉर्ट
कमांड देखो यहां पे शॉर्ट कमांड तुम्हें
तुम्हें लग रहा है क्लियर नहीं हो पा रहा
है बहुत लोगों का चैट में मुझे समझ में आ
जा रहा है आप लोगों के बातों से हा शॉर्ट
यूनिक कमांड एनक्स मैं आपको यह थोड़ा सा
समझा देता हूं यह
रही ये चलिए आ गया यहां पे ठीक है अब यहां
पे आइए ये देखिए श फूट डटी मान लीजिए आ
गया शॉर्टेड वाला आ गया आपके पास श फट .
एकटी इसमें शॉर्टेड वाला आपका आइटम जो भी
है वोह आपके सामने आ जाएगा ठीक है जो भी
शॉर्टेड वाली आइटम है वो आपकी आ जाएगी जो
भी शॉर्ट होके आएगा यहां पे अब यहां पे
देखिए यहां पे शॉर्ट करेंगे तोब यूनिक को
आप अलग एक फाइल में डालेंगे तो अब यहां पे
हम क्या करेंगे कैट रेपिड अ यहां पे करते
हैं कैट रड ज 3t हम यहां पे शॉर्ट कमांड
चला देते हैं शॉर्ट कमांड तो
शॉर्ट ठीक है ये तो समझ में आ गया कि हमने
यहां पे शॉर्ट चलाया अब इसमें हम क्या
करेंगे शॉर्ट यूनिक हमें लाना है ना यूनिक
वाले तो यूनिक वाले कर देंगे हम यूनिक चला
देंगे यहां
पे
देखो यह शॉर्ट हान य फट डटी डुप्लीकेट
लाइन कैन कैन बी रिमूव्ड विथ हान य ऑप्शन
मतलब एक हाइन य अगर लगा दीजिएगा तो
डुप्लीकेट लाइन को ये रिमूव कर देता है
ट्स इट सिंपल सा फंडा है यहां पे तो अगर
आप हान य लगाते हैं बट अगर आप यहां पे
यूनिक यह वाला लगा देते हैं यूनिक कमांड
एक्सेप्ट इनपुट फ्रॉम टेक्स्ट फाइल एंड
रिमूवस एनी सेपरेट एनी रिपीटेड लाइंस ओनली
इफ द दे आर एडजेसेंट टू ईच अदर एक दूसरे
के एडजेसेंट होते हैं आसपास होते हैं ओनली
उसको रिमूव करता है
दैट्ची है बस सिंपल सा फंडा है तो अब यहां
पे हम शॉर्ट कमांड लगा देते हैं शॉर्ट
रैपिड . ठीक है यहां पे अब यहां पे हमने
यूनिक लगा दिया यूनिक ठीक है अब इसको हम
कर देते हैं रैपिड
शॉर्टेड डटी एकटी रैपिड शड डटी एक्टी
इसमें हमने डाल दिया अब यहां पर हम कैट
रैपिड सड डटी एक्सटी करेंगे रैपिड सर्ड
डटी एक्टी डल सफन एल करेंगे एंटर करेंगे
121 यह शॉर्टेड हमारे पास आ चुके हैं 121
ही है आपके पास जो जेएस फाइल्स है यह समझ
में आ रहा है कि नहीं आ रहा पहले बताइए
मुझे अरे बाप रे मुझे बताओ भाई यार
तुम्हें समझाने में मेरा दिमाग खराब हो
गया यह मुझे बताइए कि शॉर्टेड लिस्ट जो आ
चुकी है आपके पास वह समझ में आ रहा है कि
नहीं आ
रहा अब इतना क्लियर बता दिया भाई अब तो
यहां पर सामने दिखा भी दिया शॉर्ट करके एक
यूनिक चला जाएंगे तो रिमूव कर देगा
रिपीटेड लाइनस को यह वाला चीज बस यहां पर
यहां पर एक और डी वाला भी होगा कहीं ना
कहीं आप उसको भी देख लीजिएगा कहीं पर आके
यह सब डी डीडीडीडी डुप्लीकेट का है कि
नहीं कुछ
यार ऐसे दिखा देता हूं यार रिमूव डप
ट् यूजिंग शॉर्ट कमांड शॉर्ट कमांड ऐसे भी
देख लो
ज्यादा यह
वाला सेम सेम चीज है
इतना अच्छा बताइए मुझे कितने डुप्लीकेट थे
मुझे बताइए चलिए आप ही लोग बताइए यार ह
यार 442 थे डोमेन इतने आपके शॉर्ट होके आ
रहे हैं कितने डुप्लीकेट थे बताइए मुझे ये
देखो यहां पे
शॉर्ट ये देखो यू कैन यूज द हान य शॉर्ट
कन टू अचीव द सेम रिजल्ट ठीक है ये यहां
पे कट file.txt आया यहां पे ये देखो शॉर्ट
किया file.txt यूनिक और फिर रिजल्ट आपके
पास आ गया यूनिक वाले अब यहां पे आप
डुप्लीकेट्स विदाउट क्रिएटिंग अ फील्ड
देखिए इफ यू वांट टू रिमूव द डुप्लीकेट्स
इन प्लेस विदाउट क्रिएटिंग ए न्यू फाइल यू
कैन यूज़ द t कमांड ठीक है वो तो t तो
हटाओ ब ये कोई ये तो कंफ्यूज करेगा आपको
टी कमांड टी कमांड से बेसिकली क्या होते
हैं अ आपका फाइल भी बन जाता है और आपका
काम हो जाता है दोनों काम हो जाता है ठीक
है तो यहां पे यहां पर सेम देख रहे हो श
फाटी यूनिक एंड देन आउटपुट यानी कि इतने
सारे हमारे पास जो थे वो शर्ट लाइक हमारे
पास फाइल थे जो डुप्लीकेट्स थे ठीक है यह
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा गट इट अब यहां पे
मैं मैंने तो यह कर दिया है अब यहां पे यह
जो यूनिक है ना इसमें मैं हाइन डी लगा
देता हूं हाइन डी और एंटर करता हूं अब
इसको काउंट करता हूं हान एल यह देखो 121
ठीक है अब यहां पर मैं क्या कर देता हूं
हाइन डी लगा देता हूं कैपिटल डी और अब
देखो यहां पे तो यह 442 टोटल जो आपके पास
आ रहे हैं टोटल बेसिकली जो आपके पास लाइंस
आ रही है टोटल 442 व सारी 442 आपकी आ गई
ठीक
है क्या बोल रहे हो भाई ये हां ठीक है ठीक
है
बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल सही तो
हमारे पास यूनिक आ चुकी है फाइल्स यूनिक
फाइल्स क्या आ चुकी है हमारे पास रैपिड
शॉर्टेड में आ चुकी है कितनी है हमारे पास
रैपिड शड डड सनल एंड यह हमारे 121 जस
फाइल्स हमारे आ चुके हैं चलिए बहुत बढ़िया
अब देखना होगा तो आप कैसे देखिएगा एंटर
कीजिएगा एंड यहां पर आपके पास भी फाइल्स य
पर जेएस वाली जितनी भी फाइल्स है यहां पर
आपके सामने आ गई 121 ठीक है
चलो यह तो आपने एक फाइल यह निकाल लिया
जेएस फाइल अब इसके अलावा और भी टूल्स है
अब जो नेक्स्ट टूल की तरफ हम जा रहे हैं
वह है गेट जेएस चलिए लेट्स
सी गेट जेएस गेट जेएस गिट हब यह भी अच्छी
टूल है यू कैन यूज दिस टूल आल्सो गेट जस
ठीक है यह देखिए हम इस पर चलते हैं क्या
ये गेटस इज अ टूल टू एक्स्टेक्स्ट ऑल द
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स फ्रॉम अ सेट ऑफ गिवन
यूआरएल ये सेम वही टूल है सेम उसी तरीके
से काम करता है गिवन यूआरएल जैसे कटाना आप
यूज़ कर रहे हो वैसे ही यह भी काम करेगा
तो इसको मैं ज्यादा कवर अप नहीं करने वाला
हूं बस आपको मैं बता दे रहा हूं कि कुछ इस
तरीके से यह भी निकालता है एंड पॉइंट्स जो
है फाइंड करके आपको देता है तो आप इस टूल
को भी गेट जस को भी अपने लिस्ट में टाइ
मतलब अपने लिस्ट में जो है आप इंक्लूड कर
सकते हैं ठीक है एवरीवन गॉट समझ में आ रहा
है
सबको एवरीवन गेटिंग
ना
चलिए चलिए बढ़िया बढ़िया लगा अगर आपको पता
चल रहा है तो नाइस ट्स ग्रेट एंड कितने
लोग हैं यहां पे
अच्छा चलिए अब हम यहां
पे अब हम क्या करने वाले हैं नाउ वी आर
गोइंग टू फाइंड सीक्रेट्स इनसाइड द
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स सीक्रेट्स हम फाइंड
करेंगे कुछ हमें सीक्रेट मिल रहा है कुछ
हमें कुछ चीजें मिल रही है वो हम फाइंड
करके ट्राई करेंगे फाइंड करने का तो हमारे
पास एक लिस्ट बनी हुई है यहां पे रैपिड
शॉर्टेड नाम से जेएस फाइल्स की हम इसमें
से सीक्रेट्स निकालने की कोशिश करेंगे एंड
इसके लिए जो हम टूल यूज करने वाले हैं वो
है सीक्रेट फाइंडर टूल चलिए सीक्रेट
फाइंडर टूल आ जाते हैं यहां पे गिट अप
रिपोजिटरी पे इसको कन्फर कर लेना है कैसे
कंफिल करना है आपको सिंपली य आप नीचे आ
जाइए कुछ इस तरीके से गेट क्लोन करके आपको
करना होगा और तो कुछ ऑप्शन इसका है नहीं
गेट क्लोन करना है सीक्रेट फाइंडर में
जाना है रिक्वायरमेंट्स को इंस्टॉल करनी
है एंड देन आपको चला देना है चलिए तो गिट
क्लोन कर लेते हैं यहां
से कॉपी
किया गेट क्लोन यहां पर एंटर किया क्लोन
कर देते हैं सीडी सीक्रेट फाइंडर इसमें
चले जाते हैं एलएस कर लेते हैं
रिक्वायरमेंट टीटी फाइल है एक तो यहां पे
चला देते हैं रिक्वायरमेंट्स के लिए क्या
चाहिए पिप 3 इंस्टॉल h r requirement.txt
ठीक है यहां एंटर करते हैं ओके यह क्या आ
रहा है दिस पाइथन इज एक्सटर्नली मैनेज्ड
अच्छा ठीक है देन आपको इसको वैसे इंस्टॉल
करना पड़ेगा कट requirement.txt कर लीजिए
यह सारे रिक्वायरमेंट्स इसके इंस्टॉल होने
चाहिए ठीक है बस और कुछ भी नहीं है तो मैं
क्या करता हूं एट इंस्टॉल आप ऐसे भी
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं python3 न एंड देन हम
देते हैं आरई क यू एस टी एस रिक्वेस्ट
फाइल एक इसको इंस्टॉल कर दीजिए देन पाइथन
3 पाइथन 3 एंड देन रिक्वेस्ट को भी
रिक्वेस्ट को भी करना है देन पाइथन 3 एंड
देन जेस ब्यूटीफायर जे एस बी ई ए यू टी आई
एफ आई ई आर ब्यूटीफायर
देन पाइथन 3 एंड देन आपका है एल एक्स एमएल
इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेते हैं लेट्स सी सारे
सारे इंस्टॉल ऑलरेडी है सेटिस्फाइड है
दैट्ची हेल्प फाइल ओपन हो गई है एंड इट्स
वर्किंग राइट नाउ चलिए ये तो वर्क कर गया
अब मुझे सीक्रेट्स फाइंड करने हैं कैसे
फाइंड करेंगे पहले हम यह देखते हैं हम
इसको समझते हैं आप लोग थोड़ा ध्यान
दीजिएगा ठीक है अब अब इसको थोड़ा ध्यान
दीजिएगा देखिए सीक्रेट्स हमें फाइंड करने
हैं हमारे पास जावास्क्रिप्ट की पूरी
फाइल्स है उसमें से हमें सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड करना है मान लो सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड करना है ठीक है हमें
क्या करना है सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
करने हैं चलिए अब इसको कैसे फाइंड करेंगे
किस तरीके से फाइंड करेंगे पहले हम उसको
समझते हैं थोड़ा सा देखते हैं सभी लोग देख
रहे हैं एवरीवन ध्यान इधर है ना सब लोग का
ध्यान है पहले बता दीजिए मुझे मैं देख रहा
हूं फोन में भाई फोन में देख रहा हूं मैं
बताओ चैट में देखता हूं मैं सभी
सब सीक्रेट फाइंडर यूज करेंगे हम जरूरी
नहीं है अभी मूव करने का जरूरी नहीं
है अ ट्स नॉट
नीडेड
दैट्ची
हम चलिए तो अब मैं अब मैं क्या करूंगा
यहां पे यूज करूंगा कौन सा
अ वो वाली फाइल एलएस करते
हैं रैपिड सॉर्टेड वाली फाइल ठीक है रैपिड
सॉर्टेड वाली हम फाइल यूज करेंगे तो हम
कैसे कैसे करेंगे देखो कैट यहां पे कैट
लिखा ध्यान देना कैट रैपिड शॉर्टेड ड
txt.gz
यहां पर हम एक ऑटोमेशन करेंगे छोटा सा ठीक
है एक छोटा सा ऑटोमेशन करेंगे इसमें हम
ऑटोमेशन में एक बैस स्क्रिप्टिंग करेंगे
बैस स्क्रिप्टिंग में वाइल लूप का यूज
करेंगे तो हमने ग्रेप यहां पर पाइपलाइन दे
दी अब यहां पर करते हैं हम यहां पर वाइल
वाइल रीड ठीक है हम क्या करें रीड यूआरएल
हमने क्या किया एक यूआरएल हम रीड यूआरएल
कर रहे
हैं वाइल रीड यूआरएल जब रीड करो डू तब डू
करो करो क्या करो पाइथन 3 क्या करो भाई
पाइथन 3 उसके
बाद सीक्रेट फाइंडर में सीक्रेट
सॉरी यह वाला टूल चलाओ सीक्रेट फाइंडर के
अंदर सीक्रेट फाइंडर ड पवा चलाओ यह वाली
टूल चलाओ उसके बाद हाइन आई सीक्रेट फाइंडर
में हान आई क्यों दे रहे हैं देखिए मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं इसकी इस पर चलके हाइन
आई से इनपुट देते हैं कोई भी यूआरएल या
फाइल या फोल्डर कोई भी इनपुट देते हैं
इसको यूज करने का तरीका क्या है देख लीजिए
यहां पे python3 सीक्रेट फाइंडर हान आ कोई
भी यूआरएल या फाइल दे दीजिए उसके बाद हान
रिजल्ड html5 अगर
अब यहां पर यूआरएल को जो रीड करेगा यह जो
यूआरएल रीड करेगा ना यहां पे तो यह यहां
पर एक वेरिएबल हम दे देते हैं जहां पर
सारा स्टोर होगा यूआरएल जिसको रीड करेगा
जैसे ही वाइल रीड यूआरएल रीड यूआरएल होगी
कैट इसमें से कैट इस
वाले फाइल से जब यूआरएल को रीड करेगा उसको
स्टोर करेगा सारे यूआरएल को कहां पर
भैया ये एक वेरिएबल के अंदर में यूआरएल
इसके बाद हाइन ओ आउटपुट देगा सीआई मोड में
ही आउटपुट चाहिए हमें भाई ठीक है बस और
कुछ भी नहीं सीआई मोड में हमें आउटपुट
चाहिए बस सिंपल सी चीज है यही हमें चाहिए
और तो कुछ चाहिए नहीं फिलहाल के लिए हमने
इतना सारा काम किया एंड अब जो है सीएल आई
में करके हम यहां पे अब हम यहां पे क्या
[संगीत]
करेंगे यह हमने वाइल रीड यूआरएल कर दिया
अब हम यहां पे
इसको डन कर देते हैं लूप को डन कर देते
हैं आई होप सो कि चलना तो चाहिए लेट्स
एंटर लेट्स सी नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं गलत
गलत
गलत यहां पे यूआरएल को क्या किस में किया
हमने यहां
पे कहां गया
हमारा हान
स ठीक है अब यहां पे क्या करते हैं गाइस अ
यहां पे हान सीआई अब इसको हम एक फाइल में
डाल देते हैं लेट्स अ फाइल में सीक्रेट्स
अड txt.gz
हमने क्या किया सीक्रेट एक्टी में इसको
हमने डाल दिया एंड यहां पर हम डन कर देते
हैं लेट्स प्रेस
एंटर हमने कुछ गलत किया क्या वाइल हमने सब
सही किया ना वाइल लगाया वाइल रीड यूआरएल
डू डू पाइथन 3 सीक्रेट पवा हमने एक
वेरिएबल यहां पर वेरिएबल टाइप कर देते हैं
वेरिएबल टाइप कर देते हैं यहां पर सीक्रेट
[संगीत]
डॉट
कुछ गड़बड़ हो रही
है यहां पर हम हमारा दिक्कत क्या आ रहा है
हमारी दिक्कत क्या आ रही
है
यूआरएल
डू यूआरएल यहां पर दे दिया हमने डन एंड
हमने हान सील आई
ओके
कुछ यहां
[संगीत]
पर यहां पर कुछ तो मिस्टेक हो रही
है ओके डू वन
थिंग कुछ गड़बड़ हो रही है हाफ आई य
[संगीत]
कुछ हमने गलत किया यार कहीं
पे क्या गलत कर रहे हैं मैं क्या गलत कर
रहा
हूं ये सेमी कॉलन दे रहा हूं क्या मैं गलत
कर रहा हूं
[संगीत]
क्या
नहीं हा क्या गलत हो रही है यहां पे यार
यहां क्या हम कोड में क्या मिस्टेक कर रहे
हैं कैट कुछ छोटी मोटी चीजें होंगी बस जो
हमारी छूट रही है एंड हमारे पकड़ में नहीं
आती है
बताइए ओ हो हो हो हो
हो
अ नहीं नहीं वाइल रीड यूआरएल तो सही
है अ वाइल
रीड नहीं वाइल रीड तो सही
है हम यहां पे ना एक काम करते हैं
अ एक काम करते हैं हान ओ यूआरएल यहां पे
टाइप किया ना हान ओ दे देते हैं एंड यहां
पे सीएल आई में इसको हम एक टारगेट में डाल
देते हैं लाइक
सीक्रेट डॉटी एकटी देन हम सेमीकलन देके डन
कर देते हैं आई थिंक ये होगा हां यहां पे
थोड़ी मिस्टेक हो रही थी यहां पे कुछ इस
तरीके से आपको करना है एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
थोड़ा सा मैंने बोला ना थोड़ा सा मिस्टेक
हो रहा था अपना बेसिकली डन को तो हम बाद
में जब डू आपने शुरू कर दिया है वाइड लूप
उसके बाद लास्ट में आप डन करते हैं एंड
वहां सेमीकलन आपका नहीं होता है दैट वाज
आवर मिस्टेक मिस्टे आप सेमीकलन आपको तब
लगाते हैं जब आप उसको खत्म करते हैं कोई
भी जो आपने स्टार्ट किया है तो हमने
स्टार्ट जो किया था उसको खत्म किया एंड
यहां पे डन किया डन करके स्रेट t एकटी जो
है एक फाइल क्रिएट हो जाएगी एंड इसमें
जितने भी सीक्रेट्स अगर ये कुछ फाइंड करता
है तो यह आपको निकाल के देने की कोशिश
करेगा सो लेट्स सी कुछ निकालता है कि नहीं
निकालता देखते हैं तो फाइनली वी गॉट
फाइनली मतलब कर दिया हमने अदर वाइज मैं
अभी चैट जीपीटी की तरफ जाता कि आखि दिक्कत
हो कहां रही है छोड़ी सिल्ली मिस्टेक्स थी
बस और कुछ
नहीं ठीक
है सब लोग बता रहे थे आप लोग बट आप लोग
कुछ उल्टा पुल्टा बता रहे थे डन से पहले
लगेगा हां यह सही था अ खाई खाई जी का सही
था खाई नाम क्या है यार चलो तो वेट करना
पड़ेगा हमें फॉर द आउटपुट इन सक्रेट एकटी
देन सट एकटी को ओपन करेंगे देखते
फिर यह अभी काम कर रहा है अपना क्योंकि
बहुत सारे यूआरएल थे ओबवियसली तो जितना
फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेगा
करेगा सीक्रेट फाइंडर का यूज हो रहा है
यहां पे सीक्रेट फाइंडर जो है वह किस
तरीके की चीजें फाइंड करता है यहां
पे इसकी डॉट पवाई फाइल देख लेते हैं खोल
के यहां आते हैं यहां जाते हैं यह देखिए
क्या क्या फाइंड बताए रिजेक्स क्या-क्या
इसके google's
google.it देगा एंड उसमें आपके जो है वो
कुछ अगर फाइंडिंग होगी तो आपको दिखेगी इस
तरीके से हम सीक्रेट्स फाइंड करते
[संगीत]
हैं अच्छा कमांड ठीक है आयुष चौधरी इ देर
सर आई हैव बीन फॉलोइंग यू सिंस अ वीक एंड
आई एम लविंग योर कंटेंट इट्स रियली वर्थ
इट टू वच योर वीडियोस रिसेंटली आई एम ऑन द
वीडियो नंबर थ्री ऑफ दिस प्लेलिस्ट थैंक
यू फॉर योर एफर्ट सर थैंक यू आयुष एंड
प्लीज कंटिन्यू टिल द लास्ट वीडियो काफी
कुछ अभी सीखने को मिलेगा काफी कुछ है
ऑलरेडी
इसमें सो जस्ट
वेट मजा है ना यह यह बस स्क्रिप्टिंग का
पावर है
भाई हां यू कैन ड
कीवर्ड देखो यहां पर दिए भी हुए हैं
एक्स्ट्रा कीवर्ड्स आप ऐड कर सकते हैं
स्रेट फा प में देखिए य नीचे आ जाइए यहां
पर इन्होने दिया भी हुआ है देखिए ओपन
सक्रेट फंडर पवा ए ड योर रेक्स आप इसमें
अपना रेजे डाल सकते हैं जो इन्होने डाला
हुआ है इसके अंदर डाल सकते हैं खुद का
कीवर्ड और भी ज्यादा जो भी डालना है डाल
सकते ठीक है तो यहां पर यह रिजल्ट आपको शो
करेंगे थोड़ी देर में थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा ही
यली ठीक
है चलिए तो यह मैं क्या करता
हूं
इंस्टॉल
यही तो है भाई चलिए यह हो गया अब यहां पर
मैं एलस करता हूं मेरे पास एक सीक्रेट डटी
एक्टी होना चाहिए लेट्स रीड दिस सक्रेट
एक्सटी एंड यहां पर हमें ज्यादा कुछ नहीं
मिला है हमें एक चीज मिली है पॉसिबल
क्रेडेंशियल एंड
पासवर्ड कॉलन जीरो पी सोडो ठीक है हमें
ज्यादा कुछ नहीं मिला है इसके अंदर में
बहुत ही लिमिटेड चीज मिली है
दैट्ची क आउट किए बट उसमें एक में पॉसिबल
क्रेडेंशियल में इसने वो चीज निकाल के
दिया बट इसमें भी ज्यादा कुछ खास हमारे
पास था नहीं अब ये बड़ी लिस्ट होगी उसको
आपको भी करना पड़ेगा उसको आपको देखना
पड़ेगा हमने सिंपल सा ही एक चीज किया हुआ
था ठीक है यहां पे
secret.com आपको सामने दिखाएगा देखिए यहां
पे सारी चीजें सामने रिजल्ट्स जो है आपको
शो करेगा
देखिए यह
देखिए दिख रहा है
आपको पॉसिबल क्रेडेंशियल यहां पे कुछ कुछ
जो भी पासवर्ड रिलेटेड फील्ड्स है बस उनको
यह बताता है कि ये चीज हो सकती है लियो की
अकाउंट एस
आईडी ग कैप्चा ठीक है नॉट
इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ एपीआई कीज वगर आ जाए तो
अलग बात है यह पॉसिबल क्रेडेंशियल
सक्सेस ठीक है ट्स
इट एपीआई एरर यहां पर कुछ क्रेडेंशियल
यहां पर कुछ कुछ चीजें आई है मतलब इस
तरीके से चीजें आ रही है आपके पास इस
तरीके से आप चेक आउट कर सकते हैं बहुत
सारी चीजें हैं आपको फाइंड करना है
बेसिकली बस और कुछ नहीं आपको फाइंड करना
है क्या फाइंड करना है कुछ इस ये सारी चीज
आपको फाइंड करनी है चलो मैं आपको दिखा
देता
हूं आपको यह सारी चीजें एडब्ल्यू एस की हो
गई एडब्ल्यू एस सीक्रेट की हो गई एपीआई हो
गई एपीआई की हो गई पास डब्ल्यू डी हो गया
पीडब्ल्यूडी हो गया हिरोक से रिलेटेड कुछ
हो गई स्लैक से रिलेटेड कुछ हो गया फायर ब
से रिलेटेड कुछ स्गर रिलेटेड हो गया एस
एडब सीक्रेट की से रिलेटेड हो गई एड उसकी
से हो गई पासवर्ड से रिलेटेड हो गई एफटीबी
पासवर्ड से रिलेटेड हो गई जेडीबीसी से हो
गई डेटाबेस से रिलेटेड कुछ हो गया
एसक्यूएल से रिलेटेड कुछ हो गया सीक्रेट
जट रिलेटेड हो गया कॉन्फिडेड कुछ हो गया
एडमिन से रिलेटेड कुछ हो गई पीडब्ल्यू से
रिलेटेड कुछ हो गई यहां पे जेसन से
रिलेटेड कुछ हो गया आपका जीसीपी यहां पे
एसटीडी एसटीडी एसटी एक्सेस से रिलेटेड हो
गया ईएनवी से रिलेटेड हो गया एसएसए की से
रिलेटेड हो गई गिट से रिलेटेड हो गई
एक्सेस की से हो गई सीक्रेट टोकन जो भी है
सीक्रेट टोकन वगैरह हो गया ओथ टोकन हो गए
ओथ टोकन सीक्रेट ये सारी कीवर्ड्स आपको
फाइंड करने हैं पा पासवर्ड हो गया जो भी
चीजें आप ये सारी एक्सेस जो चीजें वो
फाइंड करेंगे ठीक
है डू इट ऑन वन वेब एज वेल एज फिर हम रियल
पे आके करेंगे वीडियो में ट्राई करेंगे
नहीं ठीक है वन वेब पे क्या है आपको
बेसिकली जो चीजें फाइंड करेंगे आप रियल
में भी आप फाइंड कर रहे हैं तो आपको चीजें
समझ में आ ही रही है ठीक है आपको समझने से
मतलब है बाकी चीजों से मतलब नहीं होना
चाहिए समझ में आना चाहिए
दैट्ची वी आर गेटिंग यह देखिए यहां पे ट
अकाउंट ए एस आईडी है नॉट नॉट अ सेंसिटिव
थिंग और भी बहुत सारे यहां पे रिजल्ट्स
आपके पास आए जो जो चीजें आपको यह फेच करके
देगा यह आपको यहां पे मिल जाएंगी यह देखिए
पासवर्ड इनवैलिड साइन इन ठीक है
नथिंग यह देखिए देखो कितनी सारी चीजें
तुम्हें निकाल के दे रहा है समझ में आ रहा
है कुछ इस तरीके
से यह सारी चीजें निकालो चलो इसको मैं
क्लोज कर देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए बहुत हो
गया वी कैन यूज दिस कमांड समझाने के लिए
लिए बोल रहे थे यहां पे कमांड में समझा
देता हूं कैट किया रड श
tt3 सक्रेट फर
secret.com यरल इसमें है उस यूआरएल को रीड
करेगा यह वाइल रीड यूआरएल बस यही काम है
इसका एंड इस वेरिएबल में इसको स्टोर करेगा
जिस परे सीक्रेट फाइंडर टूल रन होगा और वो
आपको आउटपुट देगा जो भी सीक्रेट्स है उसको
फाइंड करके एंड यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट को
क्लोज कर दिया डन करके समझ में आ
गया गॉट इट इतना समझ में आ गया होगा
चलिए चलिए यह तो समझ में आ गया चलिए अब
मैं इसको यहां पर क्लियर कर देता हूं
क्लियर क्लियर ठीक है अब इसमें आप एक और
चीज कर सकते हैं क्या आप कर सकते हैं मैं
वो भी आपको समझा देता हूं मैं आपको वो भी
बता देता हूं जैसे हमारे पास एक फाइल है
ना यहां पे कैट एलएस कर देते हैं एलएस कर
देते हैं यहां पे कौन सी है रैपिड शटेड कट
अ यह
वाला यह वाला कमांड यहां से कॉपी किया
ग्रेप कर रहे हैं सिंपल सा चीज है यहां पे
रिकसिव ग्रेप कर रिकसिव ग्रेप कर रहे हैं
ट्रोपी एंड यहां पे हम मेंशन कर रहे हैं
कौन-कौन सी चीजें हमके फाइंड करना है हमें
कौन-कौन सी चीजें हमें निकालनी है
दैट्ची ठीक है एडब्ल्यू सीक्रेट और ये सब
चीजें ये हम निकाल के कोशिश कर रहे हैं और
यहां पे एंटर करेंगे तो यहां पे अब जो है
यह ग्रेप करेगा एंड व्हाट इज
दिस लेट्स अच्छा हमने कुछ गलत किया
क्या
चलिए हमने यहां पर गलत क्या किया है यह
बताइए मुझे यहां पर मिस्टेक क्या है यहां
पर हमने कैट रैपिड श ड एक् यहां पर किया
इसमें हमने यहां पर हम यहां पर क्या
मिस्टेक कर रहे हैं मुझे
बताइए हम यहां पर क्या मिस्टेक कर रहे
हैं चलिए मुझे बताइए यहां पर हम क्या
मिस्टेक कर रहे हैं
कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं व्ट मिस्टेक्स
व व्ट मिस्टेक वी आर डूइंग हियर लेट मी नो
गाइस बताइए
जरा बताइए मैं देख रहा हूं पाइप सेपरेट
कमांड ठीक
है
अच्छा यह यह वाली चीज हटा देते हैं ठीक
है ठीक है यह वाली चीज मैं हटा देता हूं
यहां
पर यह वाली हटा देते हैं एंड नाउ नाउ
लेट्स सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग
क्या हो रहा है
ये सेम हमने किया हमने हटा दिया यह
चीज हां बताइए बताइए
पाइप
पाइप पाइप पाइप ठीक
है
इनवर्टेड कमवा का डिफरेंस इनवर्टेड कवा का
डिफरेंस ठीक है एक का सुनो सुनो सुनो देखो
देखो मैं एक सिंपल सी चीज बताता हूं यहां
पे यहां पर देखो तुम्हे एक फाइल यहां पर
मैं फाइल दिखाता हूं तुम्हें पहले
न्यूक्लि का जो था ना हमारे पास कहां था
यह देखो यहां पर यह तुम्हें दिख रही होगी
रेजे जो दिख रही है यहां प तुम्हे रिजेक्स
रिजेक्स ये यूज हो रही है ठीक है अब यहां
पर एक काम कर देते हैं व्हाट वी आर गोइंग
टू डू हम यहां पे सिंपल सा एक फंडा
निकालते हैं सिंपल सा एक फंडा चलाते हैं
बहुत ही सिंपल सा निकालते हैं ठीक है क्या
करते हैं सिंपल सा ठीक है अब क्या करते
हैं देखो यहां पे हम यहां पे क्या करते
हैं इसको समझते हैं पहले कैट रड s फाइल है
हमारी ठीक
है अब यहां से हमें एडब्ल्यू एस यह वाली
मान लो फाइंड करनी है ग्रेप हान r हान e
एडब सॉर्टेड की और एंटर करते हैं अब देखो
जैसे हमने ये किया अब ये क्या रहा क्या
किस तरीके से कर रहा है ये फाइंड कर रहा
है एडब्ल्यू एस की सीक्रेट्स की जो भी
यहां पे कीज फाइंड हो रही है यहां पे जो
भी चीजें यहां पे मिल रही है यहां पे अगर
कुछ कुछ ऐसा कुछ ये फाइंड करने की कोशिश
कर रहा है एडब्ल्यू एस एक्सेस की
पर्टिकुलर ये हमें फाइंड करके दे रहा है
ठीक है अब मुझे देखो इसका मतलब क्या हो
जाता है इसकी जो इनपुट है इस इसकी जो
आउटपुट है आउटपुट क्या है इसके अंदर जेएस
फाइल्स है इसके लिए इनपुट का काम
करेगी ठीक है
समझ में आ रहा
है समझ में आ गया मैं मैं समझ गया शके
आपकी बातों को ठीक है अब यहां पर अब मुझे
क्या चाहिए मैं तो इतना कुछ कर गया ग्रिप
हमने यहां पर कर लिया अब सिंपल हम इसको एक
फिल्टर लगा देते हैं
स्टार डॉट जस य हमने लगा दिया स्टड जए और
एंटर कर देते हैं यहां पर एसे स्टड जस नो
सच फ फाइल और डायरेक्टरी नहीं नहीं यह
क्या कर रहे हैं हम यहां प अब मुझे अब
यहां पर चाहिए पासवर्ड ऐसे एंटर किया
मैंने पासवर्ड तो अब यह इसको फाइंड राइट
राइट राइट देखो यहां
पे एक काम करते हैं सेम कमांड है यहां
पे
लेट्स कॉपी
इट लेट्स गो टू चैट
जेपीटी एंड लेट्स एंटर
हियर ये देखो इट्स लु लाइक यू आर ट्राइड
टू सर्च फॉर सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन इन फाइल
यूजिंग ग्रेप अ कमांड हाउ एवर द कमांड यू
प्रोवाइडेड एज अ सिंटेक्स एरर यू नीड टू
एंक्लोज द पैटर्स विद अ विद इन सिंगल और
डबल कोड्स अ टू यूज द हाई फनी इंट्रॉप ठीक
है ऑप्शन फॉर द एक्सटेंडेड ठीक है तो इसने
सेम चीज हमने जो किया था वही चीज यहां पे
यह कर रहा है एंड या मैंने बताया था सिंगल
डबल कोट ऐसे करने के
लिए एंड प्लीज नोट दैट द कैट टू डिस्प्ले
द फाइल कंटेंट्स एंड देन पिं टू मे नॉट बी
मोस्ट सफिशिएंट तो अ इट द फाइल इ ला यू
माइट यूज़ द ग्रेप डायरेक्टली ऑन द फाइल
तो यहां पे यह ग्रेप जो है डायरेक्टली ऑन
द फाइल यहां पे यह बोल रहा है करके हम कर
सकते हैं तो हमारा पहले वाला जो कमांड था
वो बिल्कुल सही था बट यहां पे हम क्या कर
देते हैं डायरेक्टली ही वी आर गोइंग टू
यूज़ द ग्रेप कमांड एक बार इसके ऊपर में
ठीक है तो चलिए एक बार देख लेते हैं करके
लेट्स सी चाजी बटी
का चाजी बटी का भी यूज करना है भाई हैकिंग
में आपको जहां भी गड़बड़ लगे आपको ठीक है
सिंगल
कोट
एंड सिंगल कोट एंड यहां पर हमें दे देना
है
रैपिड
जेएस क्या नाम था
भाई रैपिड शॉर्टेड डटी एक्सटी ये किया
एंटर कर दिया एंड फिर हमें जो है यहां पे
बेसिकली बहुत सारी रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगी एंड
यहां पे
[संगीत]
आपको ग्रेप फन एर एंड रैपिड रैपिड सॉर्टेड
यह वाली कमांड सेम हमने चलाई है
ना बिल्कुल बट इट्स नॉट
फाइंडिंग
ओके यहां पे इसने सेम इस पर्टिकुलर जेएस
के लिए यहां पे बेसिकली क्या किया इसने
फाइंड किया है इस पर्टिकुलर कीवर्ड को यह
फाइंड कर रहा है बाकी चीजें तो यहां पे
नहीं है इसलिए नहीं तो हमें यहां पे
बेसिकली क्या करना पड़ेगा यहां पे आप
क्लियर कर दीजिए यहां
पे क्लियर कर दीजिए यहां पे एंड यहां पे
हम जो ये ग्रेप कर रहे हैं बेसिकली रिकसिव
ग्रेप तो इस फाइल के अंदर कर रहे हैं
पर्टिकुलर फाइल के अंदर हम कर रहे हैं ठीक
है अगर हमारे पास एक जेएस फाइल है जहां पे
जेएस फाइल्स पड़ी है जहां पे आपको जेएस
बेसिकली क्रेडेंशियल हार्वेस्ट करने हैं
या जो भी आपके पास लाइक कीज फाइंड करने
हैं तो आप वो पास करेंगे तो आपके पास कीज
वगैरह जो भी है वो डायरेक्टली आप ग्रेप कर
पाएंगे जो भी या एडब्ल्यू सीक्रेट की हो
गई या एक्सेस की हो गया या कुछ भी हो गया
ठीक है एंड देन यू कैन गेट द कीज ठीक है
समझ में आ रहा है एडब्ल्यू एस की सेंसिटिव
है अब देखो एडब्ल्यू एस सेंसिटिव है ठीक
है एडब्ल्यू एस सेंसिट की अगर लाइक आपके
पास कोई टोकन आ जाता है एड्स टोकन आपको
मिल जा रहा है या कोई की मिल जा रही है तो
उससे आप पर्टिकुलर एड्स बकेट को या की आप
पर्टिकुलर यूर अकाउंट को एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं उसकी जो भी प्रिविलेज है उसके
अकॉर्डिंग बस ट्स इट और कुछ भी नहीं है
उसके अकॉर्डिंग आप उसको एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं सिंपल सा चीज
है ठीक
है ठीक है चलो इतना तो आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा अब यहां पर यह तो सिंपल सा ा हो गया
चलो ये तो हमने ग्रेप ग्रेप वगैरह ये चीज
कर लिया अब इसके साथ ही आप न्यूक्लि आई का
भी यूज कर सकते हैं यू कैन यूज द न्यूक्लि
आई टेंप्लेट आल्सो मैं आपको यह दिखा देता
हूं यहां पे न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट का कैसे
यूज करना
है अ वेयर इज न्यूक्लि
आई न्यूक्लि आई गेट हब आप न्यूक्लि आई टूल
का भी यूज कर सकते हैं न्यूक्लि आई पे आप
जाएंगे यहां पे तो आपको इसको इंस्टॉल करना
पड़ेगा सिंपली इसको इंस्टॉल करने का बहुत
सिंपल सा तरीका है अ गो का यह टूल है
सिंपली इसको कॉपी
कीजिए इसको कॉपी कीजिए यहां पे इसको पेस्ट
कीजिए एंड एंटर कीजिए न्यूक्लियर इंस्टॉल
हो जाएगा मेरे यहां पे न्यूक्लि ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड है हाफ ए देंगे यहां पे
न्यूक्लि आपके सामने आ चुकी है ठीक है अब
यहां पे न्यूक्लि में कैसे करना है गाइस
देखो इसके अलावा एक और चीज बताऊंगा मैं एक
और तरीका बताऊंगा ठीक है एक और तरीका मैं
बताऊंगा एड्स इ सेंसिटिव राइट अब यहां पे
टाइप करो न्यूक्लिया हाइन एच तो हमने टाइप
किया न्यूक्लियर हान एच ठीक
है इसकी हेल्प फाइल आ गई अब यहां पे इसमें
हाइन लिस्ट होगी एक देखो यहां पे वेयर इट
इज हाइन लिस्ट हान ए पाथ टू फाइल कंटेनिंग
अ लिस्ट ऑफ टारगेट ए यूआरएल ठीक है तो हम
क्या कर देते हैं हाइन एल दे देते हैं
यहां पे न्यूक्लि आई हाइन एल दे देते हैं
यहां पे एंड देन हम इसमें पास कर देते हैं
अ रैपिड अ रैपिड शॉर्टेड ड t एकटी ये हमने
पास कर दिया उसके बाद हाइन t न्यूक्लि का
टेंप्लेट हमें देना पड़ता है तो न्यूक्लि
आई के टेंपलेट्स का मतलब क्या होता है
गाइज देखो जैसे यहां पे तुम
चलोगे न्यूक्लि आई टेंपलेट्स पे चलते हैं
यहां
[संगीत]
पे नीचे आ जाओ ये रही डेडिकेटेड रिपोजिटरी
ऑफ टेंपलेट्स इस पे चल जाते हैं
न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स पे तो ये टेंपलेट्स
है अब इसमें अलग-अलग टेंपलेट्स हैं जो तुम
अप्लाई कर सकते हो किसी पर्टिकुलर चीज पे
किसी पर्टिकुलर स्कैन पे जो कि एप्लीकेबल
होगा और आपको सीक्रेट्स फाइंड करके देगा
ठीक है तो यहां पे इस टेंप्लेट के अंदर
में अ ये फाइल टेंप्लेट जो आपको दिख रही
है यहां पे फाइल के अंदर चलते हैं फाइल के
अंदर में यहां पे जेएस है इसको एक्सपेंड
करेंगे j एलाइज वाए यह जेएस वाली आपकी
एनालिसिस वाली फाइल टेंप्लेट है आपको कीज
पे चलते हैं तो यह आपको सारे कीज मिलेंगे
एडब के
amazononline.in डायरेक्टरी दे देनी होती
है टेंप्लेट की डायरेक्टरी दे दी बस हो
गया आपने जब टेंप्लेट की डायरेक्टरी दे दी
हो गया काम खत्म और उसके बाद अब यहां पे
एंटर कर देते हैं एंटर करेंगे तो ये
स्टार्ट हो जाएगा अपना काम करना जो भी
टेंपलेट्स है उसको यहां पे अप्लाई करना
शुरू कर देगा यहां पे क्या आ रहा है
टारगेट एग्जीक्यूटिंग 129 साइन टेंपलेट्स
टारगेट लोडेड फॉर करंट स्कैन 121 नो
रिजल्ट्स फाउंड मतलब कोई भी रिजल्ट आपको
मिला नहीं ज्यादा मतलब कुछ आपको बेसिकली
आपको यहां पे कुछ फाइंड करके यहां पे मिला
नहीं इस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल के अंदर जेएस के
अंदर में ठीक है इसके अलावा आप और भी
चीजें फाइंड कर सकते हैं जैसे टेंपलेट्स
फाइल के अंदर
टेंपलेट्स के अंदर और भी टेंपलेट्स यहां
पे हमने की वाला किया था अब हम इसमें कोई
और टेंप्लेट देख लेते हैं जावास्क्रिप्ट
चलिए जावा स्क्रिप्ट वाला टेंप्लेट लोड कर
देते हैं और एंटर कर देते हैं अब ये जावा
स्क्रिप्ट वाली टेंप्लेट को लोड कर रहा है
यहां पे स्कैन कर रहा है एंड ट्राई करेगा
कुछ अगर मिलता है आपको तो दे देगा सिंपल
सी चीज
है ठीक
है
ओके क्या हुआ भाई क्या दिक्कत आ रही
है क्या हो रहा है यह चल रहा है
अभी
चलिए यहां पे आ गया इन्होंने रिजल्ट स्कैन
किया और कुछ भी हमें नहीं मिला मतलब इसने
क्या किया वह सारे स्कैंस कर रहा है
टेंपलेट्स के अकॉर्डिंग बट इसको रिजल्ट
नहीं मिल रहा है तो रिजल्ट अभी आपको नहीं
मिल रहा अगर रिजल्ट मिलेगा तो आपके सामने
वो सामने जो है वो आके आ जाएगी और यह सारे
जो है स्कैन से करके टोकन यह सारे आपको
प्रोवाइड कर रहा है तो आप इस तरीके से
न्यूक्लि का भी यूज कर सकते हैं अब इसके
अलावा देयर इज अ देर इज वन मोर टूल दैट इज
आल्सो इंटरेस्टिंग लास्ट टूल है जो मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं
मंत्रा मंत्रा यह भी काफी अच्छी टूल है
चलिए मंत्रा पे आते
हैं देखिए अ टूल यूज टू हंट डाउन एपीआई
कीज लीक्स इन जेएस फाइल्स एंड पेजेस जेएस
फाइल्स में ए एपीआई लीकेज जो होती है उसके
लिए ये टूल बनी हुई है ठीक है बहुत सिंपल
सा तरीका है मंत्रा को इंस्टॉल करना है और
इसको चला देना है चलिए देखिए कैसे इंस्टॉल
करना है गो का टूल है यहां पे कमांड डाला
यहां पे गो इंस्टॉल मंत्रा एंड इट शुड बी
इंस्टॉल्ड चलिए देखते हैं इंस्टॉल हो रहा
है
आपका ओके
शके थैंक यू चलिए यह हो गया अब मंत्रा को
लच कर देते हैं मंत्रा हान h या फिर
डायरेक्ट मंत्रा लच करते हैं कुछ इस तरीके
से मंत्रा जो है आपकी लच हो जाएगी देखिए
यह मंत्रा लच हो गई
आपकी ओके ठीक है यह मंत्रा लच हो गई अब
इसमें कैसे यूज कैसे करना है मंत्रा की
चलिए देखिए यहां
पे जो भी फाइल है जेएस वाली उस परे मंत्रा
को आपको चला देना है ट्स इट बस सिंपल सा
चीज है ये देखिए कैट एंड
अ
रैपिड रैपिड जेएस नहीं रैपिड शड डटी एंड
इस पर चला दीजिए मंत्रा एंड एंटर कर दीजिए
अब आपने जैसे ही चलाया अब यह पॉसिबल जो भी
आपके कीवर्ड्स है जो भी लाइक सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन एपीआई लीकेज अगर कुछ हो रही है
तो ये आपको यहां पर सामने लाकर देगा अब यह
बड़े-बड़े जैसे ज्यादा ज्यादा यूआरएल हैं
वैसे हैं तो आप यह चलाइए एंड आपका काम हो
जाएगा सिंपल सा फंडा है तो आप मंत्रा टूल
को भी यूज कर सकते हैं तो हमने बेसिकली
क्या किया हमने मैं यहां पे आपको दिखा
देता हूं वी यूज टूल्स टूल्स कौन से यूज
किए हमने पहले मुझे बताते चलिए टूल्स हमने
यूज किया सीक्रेट फाइंडर हमने टूल्स और
कौन सा टूल यूज किया था कटाना हमने एक और
टूल यूज किया था गेट जेएस यह वाला टूल भी
हमने यूज किया है हमने न्यूक्लि आई भी यूज
कर लिया इसके अलावा और भी कुछ यूज किया था
क्या सीक्रेट फाइंडर किया कटाना कटाना
सॉरी कटाना कटाना किया गेट जेस किया
न्यूक्लि किया इसके अलावा वी डिड नॉट डू
एनीथिंग
[संगीत]
गेट न्यूक्लि आई का यूज किया अभी हमने
मंत्रा मंत्रा यूज किया और भी टूल यूज
किया
कोई आज के सेशन
में सीक्रेट फाइंडर कटाना गेट जस
न्यूक्लिया मंत्रा बस ट्स इट इसके अलावा
तो कुछ और था नहीं शायद सब जस यह तो भूल
ही गया
मैं सब जस हमने सब जस यूज किया ठीक है
उसके बाद हमने ग्रेप का ग्रेप ग्रिप देखा
ग्रिप में काफी कुछ किया ग्रिप का यूज
किया हमने बेसिकली ठीक
है अनयू को हमने देखा पहले भी देखा था
वैसे तो तो ठीक
है यह सारी चीजें देखी ठीक है सब जस्ट लिख
दिया मैंने तो यह देखो यहां पे यहां पर
कुछ कुछ चीजें यहां पर निकल के आ रही है
यह कुछ आपको टोकन दिख रहे हैं य पे ये
देखो कुछ टोकन यहां पे यह निकाल के दे रहा
है मंत्रा यह देखो कुछ टोकन आपको दिख रहे
हैं यह सारे लिस्ट
में यह देखो अब यह क्या है चलिए इस पर ओपन
करते हैं एंड इसमें फिर आपको यह टोकन
फाइंड करना पड़ेगा यह टोकन फाइंड कर लेते
हैं एक बार क्या है
यह लेटस कंट्रोल एफ कंट्रोल व एंड यह रही
यह टोकन है
एंड
ओके व्हिच टाइप ऑफ टोकन इट इज व्हाट इज
दिस एचआरएफ ठीक
है ओके इससे यह कुछ खास टोके नहीं है यहां
पे बट इस तरह से आपको कुछ सेंसिटिव टोकेंस
मिल सकते हैं मंत्रा टूल यह काफी इजी टूल
है काफी इजी यूज टूल है आपको यहां पर अलग
अलग तरह की चीज मिल रही है अकाउंट
डुप्लीकेट ठीक है प्रूव सक्सेसफुली
ओके यहां पर भी कुछ आपको मिला है स ठीक है
ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है यर इस तरीके
से आप सीक्रेट फाइंड कर सकते हैं मंत्रा
का यूज करके
राइट चलिए ठीक है रहने दीजिए ज्यादा
खिंचाई नहीं करनी चाहिए किसी की ओके कोई
बात नहीं लीव इट तो हमने मंत्रा इस तरह से
मंत्रा से हम कर सकते हैं ठीक
है तो जेएस फाइल एनालिसिस आपको समझ में आ
गई होगी बहुत ही सिंपल सा है जेएस की सबसे
पहले क्या करना है मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
मैं आपको एक बार समझा देता हूं स्टेप्स
क्या है फाइंड और टारगेट यह आपके टास्क भी
है यह आपको करना भी है टारगेट यह ऐड चल गई
फाइंड अ
टारगेट फाइंड ऑल सब
डोमेन
फाइंड ऑल
यूआरएल ऑफ
डोमेन ऑफ डोमेन चौथा
में
फिल्टर जेएस
यूआरएल शॉर्ट देम एंड ट्राई टू फाइंड
ट्राई टू फाइंड सीक्रेट्स
इन जेएस
लिंक्स बस सिंपल बस यही तो काम है और तो
कुछ नहीं करना है सीक्रेट्स इन जेएस
लिंक्स जो भी आपके जावास्क्रिप्ट के
लिंक्स आ रहे हैं उसमें आपको सीक्रेट्स
फाइंड करने हैं बस टारगेट फाइंड करना है
और डोमेन फाइंड कीजिए सारे यूआरएल निकालिए
जितने यूआरएल आप निकाल सकते हैं निकालिए
मेरा कहने का ये सेंस है जितने यू आरएस आप
फाइंड कर सकते हैं एक डोमेन के उतने
यूआरएल फाइंड कीजिए उसमें से जेएस यूआरएल
को फिल्टर आउट कर लीजिए जो भी
जावास्क्रिप्ट के यूआरएल है उनको निकालिए
सॉर्ट कर लीजिए भाई जो भी सॉर्टेड डॉटेड
है वो सब देख लीजिए एंड उसके बाद फाइंड
ट्राई कीजिए फाइंड करने का सीक्रेट्स का
उसमें अलग-अलग टूल्स आपके आते हैं अलग-अलग
चीजें आती है जो मैंने आपको टूल्स बताया
ही जैसे कि मंत्रा यह टूल आपका वही काम
करता है सीक्रेट फाइंडर आपका वही काम करता
है यह सब टूल्स का यूज करके आप सीक्रेट्स
फाइंड उसमें ढूंढ सकते हैं फाइंड करने की
कोशिश कर सकते हैं मैनुअली कैसे करेंगे
मैनुअली आपके पास सिंपल आपके पास
जावास्क्रिप्ट की ये फाइल है इसके अंदर आप
खोजना शुरू कर दीजिए पासवर्ड कुछ है क्या
पासवर्ड से रिलेटेड तो ये देखिए यहां पे
कुछ पासवर्ड पासवर्ड मिल रहा है कीवर्ड बट
कुछ काम का है
क्या कुछ काम का यहां पे नहीं है अब यहां
पे एडमिन यहां पे टाइप करते हैं एडमिन से
रिलेटेड कुछ है कुछ लिंक वगैरह कुछ ऐसी
कुछ नहीं यहां पे ऐसा कुछ नहीं आ र है ठीक
है अब यहां पे कुछ काम करते हैं यहां पे
एडब्ल्यू एस अ एडब्ल्यू एस रिलेटेड कुछ है
एक दो तीन ऐसा कुछ खास नहीं है अब मुझे
चाहिए यहां पे कॉ कोई लिंक जेएस फाइल के
अंदर कोई लिंक चाहिए तो अब देखो यहां पे
जेएस फाइल के अंदर लिंक लिंक मिल रही है
ये वाली स्टाइल कंपोनेंट गिट हब का गिट हब
का ब्लॉग पैकेज स्टाइल एरर ये कुछ गिट हब
के अंदर का गिट हब का लिंक आ रहा है ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं यहां पे कॉड एंटर करेंगे
अब यहां पे कोई और भी इंटरेस्टिंग यूआरएल
जो जेएस फाइल के अंदर यूआरएल है उनको भी
आप निकाल सकते हैं कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
आपको पता चल जाएंगी अब जेएस फाइल के अंदर
भी कोई यूआरएल निकालना है उसका भी आपको
मैं तरीका बता देता हूं आपको मैं कुछ चीज
बता देता हूं एक और तरीका आपको बताता हूं
सारी चीजें करने का ठीक है चलिए यह तो
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा मंत्र आपने यूज
कर लिया ओके एवरीवन गॉट सबको समझ में आ
रहा है इतना क्लियर है
भाई थैंक यू शांके
थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू चलिए यह
काम बस आपका हो गया अब आपको एक और तरीका
मैं बताना चाहता हूं यहां पर
हमारे मशीन को शटडाउन में कर देता हूं
मशीन की जरूरत नहीं है हमारे को अभी
शटडाउन हान ए नाउ मैं यहां पे मशीन को जब
भी आप बंद करें अपने वीपीएस को तो शट डाउन
हा फन नाऊ कर दीजिए और एंटर कर दीजिए मशीन
आपकी बंद हो जाएगी ठीक
है अब मैं आपको बॉब शूट से कुछ बताता हूं
करके बॉब शूट का कमाल दिखाता हूं कैसे
कमाल दिखाता हूं देखिए बॉब शूट आपके पास
होगी बॉब शूट को ओपन कर
लीजिए इसके अंदर भी आप लिंक फाइंड कर सकते
हैं जावास्क्रिप्ट के बहुत कमाल से रन कर
दीजिए बब शूट को आई एम रनिंग बब
शूट यहां पर यह मैं कंप्लीट स्टार्ट से
बताऊंगा यहां पर इसको मैं स्टार्ट कर देता
हूं बॉब शूट को स्टार्ट कर दिया प्रॉक्सी
को बंद कर देते हैं यहां पे अब मैं क्या
करता हूं गाइस यहां पे किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट के लिए जावास्क्रिप्ट की एनालिसिस
करने जा रहा हूं पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए
जैसे मेरा टारगेट कुछ भी हो सकता है जैसे
कि मेरा
टारगेट कुछ भी हो सकता है कुछ भी का मतलब
क्या है कुछ भी का मतलब कुछ भी है यार तो
कुछ भी का मतलब मैं कोई कोई सा टारगेट
क्या दे
दूं छोटा टारगेट
flipkart.com दे देते हैं ये
रेंज या ब्लैंक छोड़ सकते हैं कुछ भी आपको
डालना है तो मैं फप कार् डाल देता हूं बस
हो गया पोर्ट ये सब डालने की जरूरत नहीं
है मैं
एक्सटेंडर प आके बी एप स्टोर प आएंगे और
यहां पर जब आप आओगे तो यहां पे जे में
जाना जी एफ आई
जे जावा स्क्रिप्ट कहां गया जावास्क्रिप्ट
लिंक फाइंडर ये वाली आएगी आपको अब ये इसको
इंस्टॉल करना है एक एक्सटेंशन है बब शूट
का बट ये आ रहा है कि पाइथन एक्सटेंशन को
यूज करने के लिए जाइथन आपको इंस्टॉल करना
पड़ेगा तो इसको डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं
डाउनलोड जाइथन इस पर आएंगे ये कुछ भी नहीं
आ रहा z.org प चलते हैं डाउनलोड्स पे चलते
हैं
अब यहां पे जाइथन इंस्टॉल या स्टैंड अलोन
तो स्टैंड अलोन मैं इसका जर फाइल डाउनलोड
करता
हूं यह जर फाइल डाउनलोड हो रहा है हमारा
जाइथन का डॉट जार फाइल अब इसका क्या यूज़
है मैं आपको बता देता हूं इस जर फाइल को
मैं यहां पे अ डेस्कटॉप पे ला देता हूं
ठीक है बब शूट
में देखिए यहां पे जब आप यह देखिए टू यूज़
python2 एंड कॉन्फ़िगर इट्स लोकेशन इन बब
एक्सटेंडर ऑप्शन तो हमने जाइथन को लिया
जाइथन को लिया हमने डाउनलोड कर लिया अब
ऑप्शन पर चलते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां पर आप
देखिए पाइथन एनवायरमेंट सेट करना है तो
आपके लिए लोकेशन ऑफ जाइथन स्टैंड अलोन जार
फाइल तो सिलेक्ट करते हैं और वो जार फाइल
जो डेस्कटॉप प हमने रखा है उसको सेलेक्ट
कर लेते हैं कहां गया जाइथन स्टैंड अलोन
एंड ओपन हो गया जाइथन का हमने डाल दिया
यहां पे अब यहां पे काम हो गया अब यहां पे
चलते
हैं वापस से एक्सटेंशन बीप स्टोर पे अब
यहां पे इंस्टॉल का ऑप्शन नहीं आ रहा ना
इसको रिफ्रेश करते हैं रिफ्रेश लिस्ट हमने
रिफ्रेश किया एंड वापस से जेएस फाइंडर पे
चलते हैं जेस लिंक फाइंडर अब देखिए
इंस्टॉल का ऑप्शन आ रहा है जैसे हमने इसकी
रिक्वेस्ट सेट्स पूरी कर दी अब इंस्टॉल पे
क्लिक कर लेते हैं इंस्टॉल पे क्लिक करते
हैं यहां पे ऊपर में यह मेन्यू में बप
जेएस लिंक फाइंडर का ऑप्शन आ जाता है यह
देखिए आ गया बप जेएस लिंक
फाइंडर
दैट्ची अपने इस वाले में
अ firefox.exe
अबप को ब्राउज करिए जहां जहां भी ब्राउज
कर सकते ब्राउज कीजिए
देखिए लॉगइन पर चलते हैं इसको ब्राउज करते
हैं यह लॉगइन पैनल हमने ब्राउज किया सेलर
वाला पॉइंट इसको ब्राउज कर लेते हैं सेलर
वाली इसको भी ब्राउज कर रहे हैं लिस्ट
प्रोडक्ट
ओके ठीक है बैक करते हैं फ्लिपक पर अगेन
वापस आ जाते
हैं देन हम यहां पर नीचे आते हैं यहां पर
कोई सा भी प्रोडक्ट एक ब्राउज कर लेते हैं
य स्पेक्स को ब्राउज कर लेते हैं लेट्स
ब्राउज द
स्पेक्स यह देखिए यहां पे ध्यान दीजिए
ध्यान दीजिए सभी लोग यहां पे प्लीज ये
हमने स्पेक्स को ब्राउज
किया अब यहां पे हम काट पे चलते हैं काट
को भी ब्राउज कर लेते हैं एक बार काट को
भी हमने ब्राउज कर लिया अब जब हम ब्राउज
कर रहे हैं ना तो आप देखिए यहां पे आ जाइए
बर्प जेएस लिंक फाइंडर में एंड देखिए यहां
पे बर्प जेएस लिंक फाइंडर यहां पे देखिए
यहां पे वैली डी आरएल फाउंड यहां पे आ रहा
है यहां पे और इसने इस पर्टिकुलर जे फाइल
से के अंदर से यूआरएल निकाले यानी जेएस
फाइल्स के अंदर जेएस वाली यूआरएल है उसके
अंदर से कुछ हिडन यूआरएल सीक्रेट यर जो
आपको कहीं और लेकर जा सकते हैं कुछ
सेंसिटिव लोकेशन पर लेकर जा सकते हैं
सेंसिटिव डिटेल्स दे सकते हैं पव प2 की
बग्स फाइंड करके दे सकते हैं उस लोकेशन पर
आपको यह लेकर जाता है एंड उस लोकेशन पर आप
यहां पर पहुंच जाते हैं और यह कुछ इ यह
कुछ हिडन लिंक्स आपको मिल जाते है समझ में
आ रहा है य आपको दिख रहा है गा सबको यह
समझ में आ रहा है कैसे किस तर से हो रहा
है य कुछ शानदार चीज आपको दिख रही है देख
लीजिए
प्लीज प्लीज एवरीवन सी हियर प्लीज इधर
ध्यान दीजिए प्लीज बाद में आप लोग बात
कीजिएगा यहां पर देखिए ये लिंक्स ये कुछ
यूआरएल आपकी हो रही है यह देखिए टोकन आईडी
कंप्लीट मो टोकन आईडी ठीक है व्यू आइटम
वैलिडेट ओटीपी ये ओटीपी वाली जो यूआरएल है
वो वाली राइट यहां पे यह देखिए यहां पर
कुछ इंटरनल यूआरएल कुछ इंटरनल यूआरएल आपके
यहां
पर
ये कुछ इंटरनल यूआरएल यहां पर लीक हो रहे
हैं आपके जो यू आर गेटिंग जैसे यहां पर ये
क्या ये कौन सी यूआरएल है यहां पे एक बेड
ये बेड की है चलो कोई बात नहीं य वी आर
दिस गिविंग टेकिंग जितना तुम ब्राउज करोगे
उतना यूआरएल इसमें आता जाएगा ठीक है जितने
भी तुम ब्राउज करोगे ना जैसे जो भी चीजें
ब्राउज करनी है सिंपल ब्राउज कर लॉगइन कर
लो लॉगइन के बाद ब्राउज करो और भी मजा
आएगा ठीक है यहां पे लॉग इन कर लो यहां पे
मैं नंबर डाल देता हूं यहां पे नंबर चलो
हटाओ नंबर अभी बाद में डालते हैं ठीक है
नंबर बाद में डालते
हैं इसमें देखते
हैं देखते हैं इस परे हमारा है कि नहीं फप
का
अकाउंट ओ ओटीपी आया हुआ है तो लेट्स एंटर
द
ओटीपी तो हमने यहां पर ओटीपी डाला एंड
लॉगिन हो चुके क्या हम क्या बात है हम
यहां पे यहां पे हम लॉगइन हो चुके हैं ये
भी एक अकाउंट है मान लो तो यहां पे हमने
एक अकाउंट में यहां पे लॉगइन कर लिया ठीक
है चलिए बढ़िया है यहां पे अब हम अकाउंट
में लॉगिन करके आ गए हम इसमें भी ओपन हो
चुके हैं अ हमने ओपन कर
दिया सुपर सुपर कॉइन जोन में चल चल जा
सकते हैं हम सुपर कॉइन जोन में यहां पे
जीरो बैलेंस है यहां पे ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं यहां पे मोर पे और चीजें देख सकते
हैं यहां पे अ बेसिकली यहां पे विस लिस्ट
है गिफ्ट कार्ड्स है नोटिफिकेशंस है
प्रोफाइल है ये सारी चीजें आप देख सकते
हैं जितना आप देखेंगे जितना ब्राउज करेंगे
आपको यहां पे रियल टाइम में जो है लिंक्स
जो है यहां पे आपको मिलती जाएंगी देखिए
यहां पे ये लिंक्स आपको मिलती जा रही है
ये लिंक्स यहां प आपको आती जा रही है यहां
पे यह कुछ अलर्ट्स है यहां पे ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं यहां
पे साइड मैप में यह
रहा हां तो आपका
हां तो ये यहां पे चलिए हम और भी ब्राउज
कर ले रहे हैं यहां पे और भी ब्राउज करते
हैं यहां पर ब्राउज करेंगे ब्राउज करेंगे
और यहां पर ये हमें मिलता जाएगा ये देखिए
हमें और भी यहां पे लिंक्स मिलते जा रहे
हैं कुछ इस तरीके से ये सारी लिंक्स जो है
आपको मिलते जा रही है तो यहां पे लिंक्स
आपको मिलेंगे ये लिंक्स निकाल के दे देगा
ठीक है
दैट्ची इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम हियर ठीक है
दैट्ची
करेंटली ओके
डिजिटल फ डिजिटल ओसन पे साइन अप कीजिए
$200 क्रेडिट मिलेगा 60 दिनों के लिए एंड
दैट्ची लर्न अब मुझे बता दीजिए आप लोगों
को कुछ भी सीखने को मिला कि नहीं आज के
सेशन में बस मुझे इतना बताइए यू लर्न
समथिंग और नॉट कुछ मिला सीखने को कि नहीं
मिला लेट मी
नो चलिए बता
दीजिए आपने कुछ सीखा या नहीं सीखा आपने
कुछ आज मतलब कुछ सीखने को मिला कुछ थोड़ा
हट के कुछ लगा कुछ हट के कुछ मिला सीखने
को जेस फाइनल एनालिसिस में इतना कुछ होता
है कुछ कुछ पता चला ये सब
एवरीथिंग मिला सीखने को
ताकि मेरी मेहनत सफल लगे
मुझे
[संगीत]
चलिए ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू
एवरी बडी थैंक
यू चलिए बहुत बढ़िया अगर आपको सीखने को
मिला है तो बस एक चीज बोलूंगा जाते जाते
लाइक कर करके लाइक ठोक के जाइए और अपने
दोस्तों के बीच वीडियो को जरूर शेयर कीजिए
क्योंकि जितना आप शेयर करेंगे उतना ज्यादा
सपोर्ट उतना ज्यादा प्यार मुझे मिलता है
और उतना ही ज्यादा मुझे मजा आता है
इंटरेस्ट आता है आपके लिए कंटेंट बनाने का
ठीक है तभी मैं यहां पे आपको एकदम फ्री
कंटेंट प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं एंड फ्री
कंटेंट भी प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं और भैया
देखो टाइम क्या हो गई है ओ हो हो हो हो 2
घंटे 38 मिनट ढाई घंटे के आसपास मतलब ढाई
घंटे से आपका जो है टाइम ढाई घंटे क्लास
चल रही है वह भी बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
स्ट्रीम हुआ है गाइस सिर्फ और सिफ आपके
कारण
दैट्ची
ठीक है सो प्लीज इसको कंप्लीट करके आइएगा
प्रैक्टिस करके आइएगा और दोस्तों के भी
शेयर जरूर कीजिएगा एंड ट्स इट बस आज के
सेशन के लिए इतना
ही हां इसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं आप वे बैक
यरल कोई दिक्कत
नहीं
बढ़िया
चलिए थैंक यू सो मच गाइस एंड बहुत ज्यादा
आज हो गई सेशन थैंक यू सो मच एंड हैव
अ गुड नाइट सभी को